제가 인상깊게든 건 무질서가 질서를
만들고
>> 예
>> 또 질서가 무질서를 만든다.
>> 그래서 제가 핵심 그니까 주목했던 건
그 질서라는 거예요.
>> 음. 그 질서를 우리가 질서가
만들어지는 거는 판단하고 파악할 수
있지 않을까?
>> 예. 그러니까 이런 거죠.
>> 한국의 코스피 지수가 3천을 넘어서
4천을 가고 5천을 가고 6,000을
가고 7천을 가고 8,000을
갑니다. 예.
>> 저는 이게 어쩌면 질서 같은 생각이
드는 거예요.
>> 어 그러면 사람들이 아 코스피가
오르는 거를 질서로 받아들이게 되면
투자하게 되는 거죠. 그러니까 어느
순간 다시 무질서가 오겠죠. 근데
질서가 한번 형성되는 그런 건 우리가
판단할 수 있지 않을까? 그러면 쉽게
말해서 이게 우리 주식 투자에서는
시세 추종 투자라고 하는데 그건
가능하지 않을까? 질서라고 판단하면
>> 어 제 무식한 생각에는 어떻게
생각하시?
>> 그것도 근데 질서라고 하긴 어렵죠.
주가 주수가 오르는게 어떤 질서가
늘어났다라고 하기는 쉽지 않죠. 음.
>> 사실
>> 사실 그 이미 눈치는 채셨겠지만 저는
잘 몰라요. 근데 데이터를 통계적으로
살펴본 경험들은 있는 거죠.
>> 그래서 그걸 갖고 얘기를 드리자면
아까 말씀드린게 몇 가지
>> 그 좋치 않은 소식
예측할 수 없다. 뭐 그런 얘기를 할
수 있죠. 아, 근데 주가 그의 그
수익의 상관 관계는 아주 짧게 시간만
흐르면 소멸돼 버리는데 흥미롭게도
변동성은 오래 가는 데이터가 있어요.
그래서 오늘 이렇게 막 활발하게
변동이 크면은 그 변동은 상당히 며칠
뒤까지도 오래 가요.
>> 아.
>> 그런데 오늘 올랐다고 며칠 뒤까지
오르는다는 얘기는 전혀 하지 못.
>> 그러면이 이런 예측은 가능하겠네요.
오늘 변동성이 크니까 내일도 변동성
클 겁니다. 보통 그래. 저 앞으로이
얘기만 하겠습니다.
과학적으로 검중된 얘기입니다.
>> 진짜 잘 알려줘.
>> 어 아니 그 질서 얘기가 나와서 주식
시장에 그럼 질서가 있다라고 할 수
있나요?
>> 이게 그 이런 얘기를 질문하시면은
과학자들은 또 반문하거든요. 질서가
뭔지 정의해 달라고 부탁하죠.
>> 아
>> 근데 사실 우리가 비유적으로 다들
질서가 지금 늘어나는 방향처럼 얘긴
하지만 명확히 그럼 질서가
무엇이냐라고 이야기하면 쉽지 않죠.
음.
>> 그래서 질문하셨습니다. 제가 생각하는
질서는 자산시장에서는 많은 사람들이
생각하면서 일종의 피드백으로
움직이잖아요.
>> 음.
>> 그러면 많은 사람들이 비슷한 생각을
하게 되는 그 상황.
>> 아, 예.
>> 그게 저는 질서라고 보거든요.
>> 아, 예. 어떤 건지 알 거 같아요.
>> 네. 그래서 예를 들어서 지금
대한민국 주식 시장이 오르는데 수많은
국민들이 투자를 하기 시작했다.
>> 전 이게 비슷한 생각을 하면서 시장을
만들어 내고 있습니다. 이걸 질서라고
판단하면
>> 그러면 내일도 우리 국민 투자자들이
주식을 살 거다. 이런 예측을 하는
건
>> 어떨까요? 그거는 가능할 거 같아요.
그니까 많은 사람이 그 지금 말씀하신
것처럼이 주식 시장의 변동은 사실
굉장히 심리적인 요인이 강하거든요.
근데 그런 부분은 이제 물리학자들은
얘기하기 너무 어렵고요. 근데 지금
말씀하신 거는 확실히 맞죠. 많은
사람들이 우리나라의 주식 시장의
장례를 밝게 보면
>> 그럼 더 많은 사람들이 주식 시장에
참여하고 그러면 이제 거래량도 늘고
하면서 주가가 오를 가능성이 커지는
건 맞죠.
>> 그렇죠. 음. 음.
>> 근데 그게 또 먼 미래를 예측하는
수단이 되긴 어렵고요.
>> 아,
>> 그래서 어떤 그 전반적인 주식 시장의
장기적인 패턴은 우리나라뿐 아니라
대부분의 주식 시장은 장기적으로 보면
항상 굉장히 빠르게 성장하거든요.
그런 추세는 어느 나라나 보여요.
>> 근데 그게 맞다라고 가정하면 그런
말씀하신게 맞는 거죠. 장기적으로는.
>> 네. 제가 뭐 재미삼아 우리 교수님
물리학과 물리 전공하셨으니까
>> 물리학자들이 투자를 못 한다.
>> 못하죠.
>> 대표적 대표적인 예를 하나 보으려고
제가 차트를 하나 려왔습니다.
>> 자예
>> 가장 위대한 물리학자 누굽니까?
>> 아 뉴턴
>> 우리 뉴타 선생님 주가가 오르기 전에
잘 샀어요.
>> 응. 사긴 잘 샀어.
>> 네. 근데 주가가 막 오르고 있는
상황 속에서 팔아요. 그러다가
팔았잖아요. 근데 주가가 거의
고점에서 재매수로 하.
>> 그때까진 좋았겠다.
>> 그러다가 주가가 엄청 빠지는 순간 안
팔고 계속 들고 있어요. 그다음에
대손실이 나요.
>> 그러면서 뉴턴 우리 선생님 선생님께서
>> 이게 물리학보다 어렵다. 사람들의
감정을 읽는게 뭐 이런 말씀도
하셨잖아요.
>> 예. 뉴트이 그런 얘기를 남겼죠.
네.
>> 근데 저 약간은 오해가 있는데 뉴턴이
저때 손실을 꽤 크게 보긴 했거든요.
>> 당시 기존으로 만 파운드인가로 소대를
봤는데
>> 아 그런데 뉴턴이 제가 알기로 꽤
돈이 많아서
>> 그 정도는 뭐 괜찮았어.
>> 절로 본 적 없네.
마지막에 남긴 유산이 3만 파운드
과목 그랬던 거 많은 돈 많은
사람이어서
>> 뭐 대손실이랑 생각 안 했을 수도
>> 제가 제가 분명히 예측 생각하는데 저
주가 빠질 때 물을 탔을 거예요.
>> 근데 보니까 매수한 시점이
고점이네요.
>> 맞아요. 흥미롭죠? 그러네요. 예.
안녕하세요. 주가가 빠질 때나 오를
때나 여러분들의 밥 친구가 되고
싶습니다. 12시에 만나요.
이광수입니다. 오늘 주식 시장이
하락폭이 좀 큰데요. 어 여러분들도
많이 걱정스럽게
또 시장을 바라보실 것으로 이렇게
예측이 됩니다. 그런데이 이럴 때
있수록 저희가 기운차게 시작해 보도록
하겠습니다. 가장 기운찬 남자 박시동
대표님 어제 링게 한대 맞고
>> 박시동입니다.
>> 기운 좀 차리셨어요?네
>> 링거 투원이죠.
>> 네
>> 약물로 버팁니다.
>> 종수 고기 좀 사 줘라.
>> 아 그러니까요. 예. 네. 회식비
지원이 좀 와야 돼요.
>> 네. 알겠습니다. 그리고 오늘 권다영
앵커 님이 저희가 프로 시작하기 전에
잡힌 스케줄을 소화하시러 잠시 자리를
비우셨습니다. 아 그런데 어마어마한
손님이 오셨어요. 예. 우리 권민정
안남손님 오셨습니다. 안녕하십니까.
권민정입니다. 아침엔 뉴스로 깨우고
점심 시간에는이 시장을 소화시키러
나왔습니다.
감사합니다.
>> 아니 제가 들리는 소문에 의하면
>> 우리 권민정 안남수님이 주식계 큰
손이래요.
>> 주식 코인 뭐
>> 어
>> 네
>> 다 하신가요?
>> 총 자산이 얼마 되지 않아 가지고네
미미한 개인데 어쨌든 제 돈은 많이
들어가 있습니다.
>> 아 요즘 오늘 같은 날 주가가 빠질
빠지면 어떠세요? 그러니까요. 밥
친구인데 오늘은 멘탈 친구로 함께
하겠습니다.
>> 아, 좋습니다.
>> 예.
>> 아, 근데 지금 댓글에 권다영 안
나오서 오늘 안 나오는 거냐라고
하시는데 안 나오시는 건 아니죠?
네. 조금 있따가 나오에 나오시고
여러분 조금만 기다려 주시고요.
>> 오늘 권민정 아나운서님과 함께 시장도
정리해 보고 중요한 뉴스들 얘기를 좀
해보.
>> 네. 그래도 고민정원 선님도 예전에
경제 방송 쪽에 경험도 많으시고
그래서 사실은 뭐
>> 예 충분한 전문성과
>> 아
>> 그리고 눈속에 돈이 있어요.
>> 욕망료 등극합니까?
>> 네. 아, 돈이 강렬하게 있습니다.
네네네.
>> 아, 네.
>> 예. 오늘 시장과 관련된 주요 뉴스
어, 정리해 주시면 좋으실 것
같습니다.
>> 네. 네. 오늘
시장 관련 주요 뉴스 현재 시간
12시 기준입니다. 우리 시장
살펴보도록 할 텐데요. 국내 증시
낙폭이 장 초반부터 빠르게
커졌습니다.
어 현재 지금 7,218포인트
3.96%
하락하면서 코스피 지수가 지나가고
있고요. 코스닥도 지금 3.7%
하락하면서 1069포인트선
지나가고 있습니다. 장 중에는
하락폭을 더 키웠어요.
7,100선까지
이렇게 위협을 받다가 장중에
7,141포인트까지
밀리기도 했습니다. 어 현재 시간
6가 증권 시장에서 외국인이 지금 어
4 3조원 넘게 팔아치우면서 지수
하락을 주도하고 있습니다. 개인 홀로
매수에 나서고 있지만 지수 하락을
막기에는 역부족입니다. 코스닥 지수
역시 지금 급락을 하면서 투자 심리가
크게 위축된 모습인데요. 서울 외관
시장에서는 원달러 환율 6.5원 내린
1493원대에서 출발을 했다가 현재는
1500원을 다시 돌파하면서 외국인
수급 부담을 키우고 있습니다.
>> 네. 전체적인 시장 상황이고요. 어
오늘 정호의 머니 뉴스를 좀 정리해
보겠습니다.
>> 네. 네. 네, 오늘 주요 뉴스도
살펴보겠습니다. 첫 번째 뉴스입니다.
간밤 미국 증시에서 반도체 주가가
약세를 보였는데요. 국내 반도체
대형주에도 부담으로 작용한
모습입니다.이 삼성전자와 SK
하이닉스 모두 어제보다 하락 출발한
뒤 낙폭을 키우고 있는데요. 시가
총액 상위 10개 종목 중 하나
에어로스페이스, 에어로스페이스를
제외한 전 종목 모두 하락세를 보이고
있습니다. 국채국리 상승과 인플레이션
우려 등 거시 경제 불안이 시장의
변동성을 키웠다는 분석이 나오고
있죠. 그런만큼 21일 세에 공개되죠
미국의 극리 향방을 가음할 FMC
의사록과 엔비디아의 실적 발표에 많은
관심이 모이고 있습니다. 네. 두
번째 뉴스도 살펴보겠습니다. 최근
국내 주식 시장에서 외국인들의
매도세가 커지고 있는데요. 올해만
87조원의 순 매도를 기록 기록한
가운데 주요 지주 회사의 주식은 집중
매수한 것으로 나타났습니다. 특히이
SK와 두산 하나와 HB 현대 등은
외국인의 지분율이 일제히 상승을
했는데요. AI 전력 인프라, 조선
등의 업종에 대한 자회사의 성장성과
함께 지배 구조 개선 정책 기대가
지주사에 대한 재평가를 이끌고 있단
분석이 나오고 있습니다. 네. 다음
세 번째 뉴스입니다. 5.18 광주
민주화 운동 기념일인 어제 스타벅스
코리아가 탱크데이라는 이름의 할인
행사를 열어 논란이 되고 있습니다.
신세계 그룹은 논란에 대한 책임을
물어서 손정형 스타벅스 대표를
해임했지만 폭풍은 이어지고 있는데요.
일부 소비자들을 중심으로 온라인상에서
불매 움직임으로까지 번져가는
모습입니다.
마지막 뉴스입니다. 오늘 반도체와
현대차 등간 시장을 이끌었던
주도주들의 약세를 보이자 시장은 다른
곳으로 눈을 돌리고 있습니다. SM을
필두로 엔토주가 시장에서 눈에 띄는
흐름을 보이고 있는 건데요. 음반
판매 회복세를 발판으로 반등 조짐을
보이고 있습니다. 사실 그간 대형
거물급 아이돌의 컴백에도이 주가
흐름이 지지부진했던 엔터주인데
지금부터라도 다시 주목해 봐도
될까요? 마지막 뉴스 준비해
봤습니다.
>> 아, 감사합니다.
>> 네.
>> 오늘 아무래도 시장 뉴스가 가장 큰데
일단 주가가 빠지고 있습니다.
하락하고 있어요.
>> 네. 네.
속했고
또 그근에는어물가가
오른다. 그래서 금리가 올라가고
있다. 채권 금리가 쉽게 진정되지
않고 있는 모습입니다. 어 그런데
조금 이제 투자자들이 좀 더
심각해지는 거 아니냐 이런 생각들이
좀 많이 퍼져 가는 거 같아요.
>> 일단은 간밤에 미국 상황을 좀 예의
주시를 했어야 됐었는데요. 상황
보니까 미국 증시가 처음에는 조금
빠져었었어요. 어 뭐 이런 문제도
조금 노이즈가 계속 이어지고 그래서
좀 빠지다가 중간에 이제 트럼프
대통령이 소위 말하면 타코
>> 예 금리가 10년물이 이제 4.6을
넘어갔기 때문에 뭔가 시장에 도움되는
얘기를 하지 않을까라고 했는데 멘트가
나오긴 나왔어요. 뭐 내일로 예정된
이런 공격을 미루겠다.음 음런 기
나와서 아 이제 또는 건가라고 했는데
그 발언 이후에 미국 씨가 반등은
했는데 뭐 떨어진 만큼을 상쇄하고도
위로 올릴 정도에 확실한 반등세는
보이지 못하고 악폭을 많이 하는
선에서 약보합선에서 조금 이제
마무리가 됐습니다. 근데 이제
전체적으로 보면 그러면 미국 증시가
폭락을 하거나
>> 그 금리 우려 등등등으로 인해서 어
완전한 약세 전환이다 이렇게 보기는
어렵죠. 어 반등하면서 마무리 했기
때문에 근데 이제 내용적으로 들어가
보면 우리한테 영향을 많이 미치는
종목인 반도체 관련 섹터가 조금 어제
많이 빠졌어요.
>> 필라델피아 반도체 지수가 2.4 정도
빠졌고요. NB아도 1% 넘게 빠졌고
샌디스크 한 5% 마이크론이 한 5%
5.9 정도 빠지면서
>> 어 반도체 관련해서 조금 이제
우려섞인 모습을 보여냈고요.
아마 우리 증시에 오늘 조금 이제
영향을 많이 주고 있나 주고 있지
않나 이렇게 생각을 하는데 여기까지는
이제 전해지는 내용이고
>> 네
>> 저는 개인적으로는 좀 우려가 과하다
이렇게 생각을 하고 있어요. 왜냐면
>> 어 미국에 있는 샌디스크나 마이크론이
뭐 조금 빠진다 어쩐다 저쩐다 하는데
엄밀히 말하면 삼성전자 하이닉스가
압도적인 1, 2등이에요.
>> 예. 그니까 얘네들이 그동안 너무
많이 올랐죠. 그렇죠. 그렇죠.
>> 거의 뭐 어이 3전 하이닉스보다 지금
두 배 이상 받으면서 올라가고
있는데요. 어 너무 많이 올랐기
때문에 미국 내에서도 나름대로는 차이
실현하려고 하는 생각들이 있죠.
당연히. 그러니까 너무 많이 올라서
빠진 거예요.
>> 그죠? 마이크론 주식이 1년 동안
고민정환님 몇 % 오는 거 같으세요?
찍어 보세요.
많이 올랐거든요. 몇 % 정도 오를
거 같으세요?
200%
>> 600%
>> 어
>> 일곱배가 올라 1년 동안 엄청나죠.
>> 그러니까 그러니까 많이 올랐기 때문에
이제 부담이 되고 이제 흔들릴 수
있는 거죠.
>> 네. 그리고 한편 결국에는 우리한테
중요한 건 이제 제가 볼 땐 이건
표면적인 이유데 한번 조금 이제 깊이
한번 들어가 보면
>> 네.
우리한테 정말 중요한 거는 얘네
반도체 업체라기보다는
엄밀 말하면 M7이에요. 큰 회사들이
계속 해펙스 투자를 하면서 AI
생태에 반도체 사야 되는 이런 상황이
>> 그렇죠. 근데 어저께 M7는
강보합이에요. 음.
>> M7은 강보합이고요. 특히 이제
인텔이나 AMD는 거의 뭐
>> 어 거의 뭐 어 변동 없이 끝났어요.
-0.5니까. 그러니까 지금 어
마이크론이 5% 빠진 거는 제가 볼
때는 차익 실현인 거 같고요. 음.
그다음에 이제 인텔이나 AMD가 거의
안 빠졌고 또 M7들이 거의 안
빠지면서 광보을 만들어 냈거든요.
네.
>> 제가 볼 때는 얘네들이 멀쩡하면
결국에는 얘네들이 반토체를 사게 돼
있어요. 예. 그런 측면에서 시장에
뭐 명과 암이 다소 혼조돼 있다
이렇게 봐야 되는데 우리 장을
맞이하면서 투자자분들이 어 어제
마이크론 빠졌나 봐. 우리도 그냥
무조건 빼야 되나 봐. 이런 식으로
단편적으로 볼 일은 아니다. 시장의
좀 다이나믹을
>> 나눠서 보시자. 이런 말씀드리고요.
한편으로 반도체 회사가 마이크론하고
샌디스밖에 없냐? 그게 아니잖아요.
다른 소식도 좀 보신다면
>> 일본에 있는 키옥시아라고 있습니다.
예. 키옥시아. 예.
>> 얘네들이 시총 27위에서 출발해요.
근데 지금 몇 위에요?
>> 4위예요. 4위.
>> 오. 야.
>> 예. 음
>> 우리를 치면 저 32권 밖에 있다가네
>> 거기 삼성 하이닉스 밑까지 쫓아올
정도로 비약적으로 성장합니다.
>> 삼성 하이닉스 밑에 마이크론 밑에 밑
있는 애들이 얘예요. 얘네도 지금
어마어마한 매출 신장세 때문에 시총
4위까지 올라고요. 어저께는 상한가를
쳤어요.
>> 음.
>> 예. 그러니까
>> 갑자기 막 거래 정지되고 그런
>> 네. 그러니까지 반도체 전체적으로
메모리 전체적으로 보면
>> 실적이라든지이
파지티브한 비율를 꺾을 때가 전혀
아니다.
>> 일본 애들도 이렇게 뜨는 거 봐라.
그다음에 어저께 이제 실적 발표가
중국에서 나왔는데 중국 반도체 창신
메모리 CXMT라고 있는데 여기가 아
1분기 실적이 무려 전년 대에 비해서
719%가 늘었어요.
>> 와
>> 네
>> 여덟 배 늘었어요. 여덟 배 얘네들도
>> 얘네들은 사실 중국 내에서밖에 장사
안 하거든요. 사실상 아주 적하기
때문에. 그죠?
>> 그러니까 지금 어 삼성 하이닉스가 1
2등이고 3등하고 있는 마이크론
4등하고 있는 키옥시아 그 밑에 있는
창신 메모리 얘네들 보면 그 밑에서도
지금 이렇게 어마어마하게 올라가고
있기 때문에에 반도체 관련해서 지금
뭐 피크아웃이다, 꺾였다 이런 거
걱정할 때는 전혀 아니다. 저는 일단
그렇게 보고 있습니다.
>> 일단 실적이 받쳐 주고 있기 때문에
저희가 그런 이익 증가세를 좀
살펴봐야 될 거 같고요. 중요한 건
근데 이제 주가가 변동성이 커졌으니까
저 어제도 저희가 그런 얘기 했는데
변동성은 예측할 수 있다. 근데
어쨌든 지금 한국의 주식 시장의
변동성은 큰 건 확실합니다.
>> 근데 그 근조에는 뭐냐면 금리가
올라가니까 그리고 많이 주가가
올랐다고 판단하니까 불안한 거죠.
그니까 여러분도 똑같으실 거예요.
뭐냐면
>> 네.
내가 수익을 많이 냈어요. 물론 이제
정도의 차이는 있겠지만 그런데 수익을
많이 냈는데 막 이렇게 금리 인상되고
물가가 오른데 이런 이제 얘기들이
점점 더 크게 들리기 시작해요. 근데
시장을 봤더니 주가가 흔들려요. 그럼
어 어떻게 하고 싶을까요?
>> 빼고 싶죠. 멀미나니까.
>> 그죠? 맞아요. 맞아요.
>> 그러니까 그런 현상들이 이제 주식
시장에 나타날 수 있는데
>> 음. 이것도 있는 거 같아요. 저
국민 투자자잖아요. 국민 투자자
입장에서 최근에 주식을 하시는 분들이
굉장히 많아요. 그러니까 이런 변동성
장세를 당연히 예상하지 못했고 그냥
나는 뭐 뭐 작년부터 뭐 올해 초부터
이제 주식을 하기 시작했는데 뭐 많이
안 올랐어. 글적글쩍 뭐 한 50%
막 이렇게 얘기를 하세요 주변에
분들이. 그러니까 되게 많이 오른
거다라고를 얘기해도 그런가 하신단
말이에요. 그러니까 이렇게 빠지는
장세를 보면
>> 오 정말 구역질이 올라올 수밖에 없을
수도 있겠다.
>> 근데 권한의 흥미로운 심리적 현상이
뭐가 있냐면
>> 주가가 오른 다음에 많이 오른 다음에
빠질 때가 고통이 더 커요.
>> 그러니까 무슨 얘기냐면 예를 들어서
내가 주식을 만 원에 샀는데
>> 네.
>> 만 원에 샀는데 거기에서 빠질 때보다
올랐다가 빠질 때 고통이 커요.
>> 지금 심리잖아요.
>> 그래. 왜 그런지 아세요?
>> 네.
>> 오르면 사람들이요. 상상을 하게
돼요.
>> 쉽게 말해서 나 1천만 원 벌었으면
이제 아 차도 좀 바꿔 볼까? 뭐
컴퓨터도 사 볼까? 그러면서 1천만
원 번게 확대돼서 이만큼 커져요.
근데 조금만 안 빠져도 하나씩
줄잖아요.
>> 그렇게 아파요.
>> 그게 되게 고정스러워서 사람들이 이런
경우에 너무 쉽게 시장을 나오는
경향이 있어요.
>> 어 근데 우리는 일단 주가가 빠지면
팔아야 되는 건 맞습니다.
>> 그런데 그건 계획화에서 하는 거지
감정적으로 할 일은 아니다. 근데
이렇게 시장이 많이 오르고 빠졌을 때
특히 심리적으로 그런 경영성이
크거든요.
>> 네. 어, 저는 여러분들이 잘 계획을
세우시고
>> 대응을 하셨으면
>> 좋겠다. 그러면 지금 반도체는 그렇게
겁낼 자리가 아니다.
>> 저는 개인적으로 반도체에 관련해서 뭐
픽크아웃 설 어쩌고 저쩌고 하고
있는데 예, 전혀 그럴 상황
아니다라고 개인적으로 생각을 하고
있고요. 이제 한 가지 우려되는 거는
일단 외국인 매도세가 일단 연일
이어지고 있는데요. 요걸 좀 자세히
좀 볼 필요가 있는데
>> 지금 연초부터 어저께까지 총 누적으로
보면 100조가 넘어요.
외국매도세가이 100조원 넘는데
저희가 이제 말씀드렸습니다. 이유가
뭐냐라고 하면 일단은 걔네들도 돈을
많이 벌었어요. 그렇기 때문에 이제
차익 실현, 리밸런싱 뭐 이런게 하나
있다. 그다음에 두 번째가 전
세계적으로 영향을 미치고 있는이 금리
문제. 예. 예. 요것 때문에 국채
수익률 요런 것 때문에 아유,
불안하다. 그럼 증시 전체적으로
우울하니까 돈 많이 벌었으니까 지금
아예 빼놓고 도망가자. 당분간은 좀
쉬자.
리스크 관리
지금 다시 환율이 1500선을 가고
있어요. 그니까 이제이 환율이 사실
높으면 매도 압박이 되거든요.
>> 그래서 환율이 한동안은 좀
1430원까지 내려가다가 쭉 슬금슬금
올라간이 모습. 여기 세 가지가
겹치고 있다라는 분석인데
>> 뭐 차익 실현하는 거, 리밸런싱 하는
거 전 이거는 걱정할 필요 없다고
보고요. 예. 그 다시 뺐다가 다시
들어오거나 다른 종목으로 또
들어오거나 자기네들이 비중 조사를
한다면 다시 들어올 수 있고 전혀
그동안 안 사던 새로운 수급도 들어올
수 있기 때문에 크게 걱정한 일은
아니다고 보는데
>> 문제는 금리 문제랑 확률 문제가 제가
볼 땐 엮겨 있어요. 왜냐면
>> 작년 말에 우리나라에서 외국인들이
야, 한국 안 될 거 같아. 뭐
저번에 그니까 그 이전에 작년 말
이전에 팔 때는 야, 한국 안 돼.
환율이 너무 높아. 그래서 팔아.
음을 나가요.
>> 나가면서 환율을 다시 또 올립니다.
달러를 바꿔서 나가니까요. 그러니까
이제 팔고 나가고 팔고 나가고
나가면서 환율 올라가고 환율
올라가니까 지금이라도 더 팔자. 더
올라가기 전에 빨리 팔자. 이런 어떤
악순환이 있었는데요. 지금은 제가 볼
때는이
국채 관련해서음
전 세계적으로 불안하니까 달러가 지금
99까지 달러 인덱스가 올라갔거든요.
그 상대 통화가 전부 다 약세로 봐야
되는 거죠. 우리 말고 이런
매크로흐름이 하나 있고요. 주식을
팔아서 나가는 것 때문에 제가 볼
때는 환율이 높아지는 거 같진
않아요. 제가 볼 때는. 그럼 뭔데?
우리 채권 시장이 지금 해외 채권
아까 그 금리 얘기했잖아요. 해외
채권 시장보다 더 많이 패닉이에요.
지금
>> 우리 증시가 아 우리 채권 시장 예
그 채권에서 외국의 매도가 지금 더
세요.
>> 음. 채권 시장은 사실은 주식보다 더
크거든요.
>> 예. 그니까 제가 볼 때는 환율을
올리는 거는 어 금리 불안이라든지
일환 문제 같은 매크로 때문에
올라가는게 하나고요. 또 하나는 채권
매도로 인한 자금이 좀 나가는 거
같아요. 채권 시장은 희망이 아
죄송해요. 너무 좀 단정적인
표현이지만 단기간에 반등될 것 같은
모멘텀이 잘 안 보여요.맞아요.
>> 우린 증시는 지금 그래도 반도체 실적
좋다. 우리 이런 얘기 할 수 있지만
그러니까 채권에서 빼고 밖으로 나가는
수요가 조금 있지 않냐.
음증가는채권는
그니까밀하게 이렇게 분석을 해보면
우리 시장이 증시가 꺾였어. 그래서
나가. 그래서 환율이 올라가. 환율이
올라가니까 더 빼. 더 팔자.이
흐름은 아니고 증시는 차익 실현
리밸런싱이라고 딱 일단 여기서 월을
한번 치고요. 벽을 한번 치고 환율은
왜 오르지라고 할 때 채권 관련한
얘기, 글로벌 관련한 얘기 때문에 좀
오른다. 이렇게 보면이 악순환이 아직
시작된 건 아니지 않느냐. 이렇게
보면 글로벌리한 매크로적인 흐름,
일환 문제, 금리 문제가 만약에 전
세계적으로 어느 정도만 정리가 되면
다시 환율도 정리가 되고 그로 인해서
증시에 대한 매도 압박은 아직
걱정하지 아직은 안아도 된다. 이렇게
조금 좀 나눠 봐야 될 것 같아요.
예.
그러니까 이런 시장 상황 특히 이제
외국인 투자자들이 한국에서 많이
팔면서 여러 가지 분석 자료 뉴스들이
나오는데
뭐 그 내용들은 이제 현황 파악이니까
크게 전 관심 없는데이
>> 중에서 가장 제가 너무 기분 나빴다고
화가 났던게 뭐냐면 서울 경제에서
이런 헤드라인으로 적는데
>> 반도체 개미들이나 살아
>> 그런
>> 이런 기사가 나와요. 네. 진짜
그러니까 아직도 한국의 투자자들과
그러니까 그니까 몇 시 하는 거죠.
어 사실 이런 어떤 시장의 분석
자료들이 나와서 네
>> 아 좀 어 굉장히 좋은 충격을 받았고
>> 그 내용과 상관없이 헤드라인 자체가
기분이 나쁘네요. 예미들이나.
>> 그렇죠. 그렇죠. 아 어떻게 이런
기사를 쓰는지
>> 마지막에 설거지나 해. 너희들은 약간
이런 멸시를 깔고 있는 제목이네요.
>> 맞습니다. 서울 경제입니다. 예.
이런 기사를 쓰는 거죠. 어,
>> 좋습니다. 어쨌든 시장의 변동성이 좀
커지고 있는데
일단
>> 그럼 낙폭은 조금 1 7,100선까지
갔다가 지금 7,275까지는 일단
올리고는 있습니다.
>> 네. 계속해서 올라가고 있기 하네요.
두 가지 꼭 계속 강조하지만 첫
번째는 계획은 있어야 된다. 두
번째는 지금의 시장의 하락은 어 쉽게
말해서 거시 경제 이슈기 때문에 어
한국의 기업들 특히 반도체 어 기초
체력 그리고 이익에 대한 어떤
훼손이나 거기에 대한 부정적 의견은
아니다라는 얘기를 좀 드립니다.
>> 네. 그리고 조금 자신감을 가지세요.
예를 들어서
>> 어 새벽장에서 미국에 뭐 마이크론이
뭐 올랐다 그러면 우리도 올라겠지
이렇게 좋게 해석하는 건 괜찮아요.
근데 예를 들어서 한번 생각해
보자고요. 삼성과 하이닉스가 세계
1, 2등이 압도적이에요. 근데 예를
들어서 삼성이 파업한데 그러면 3등
4등 하고 있는 애들은 우리한테
물량이 더올려나? 가격이 더
오르려나? 우리가 거꾸로 걔네들한테
영향을 주는 거예요. 근데 어저께 야
그래도 노조가 회사랑 얘기하나 봐.
>> 협상장에 다시 들어왔대.이
블룸버그 전계든 그럼 미국에 있는
마이크론들 아 삼성파 안 하겠지 그
걔네들한 악예요
>> 이렇게 좀 주도적으로 생각해도
됩니다. 반도체 관련해서는
>> 맞습니다. 그런 차원에서는 또 오늘
삼성 노조 협상 노사 협상이 또
중요해 보입니다. 잘 해결됐으면
좋겠고요. 네. 어, 확실히 영향은
있는 거 같아요. 뭐 빅테크 회사들이
계속 질문도 많이 들어오고
>> 맞습니다. 그래서 일단 어저께는 어
다시 이제 대통령도 메시지를 냈고 또
법원 판결도 일단은 파업에 대해서
치명상을 회피하는 방식으로 판결이
나왔고 노사가 협상 자리에 앉았고
그래서 일단 그것까진 좋은데
>> 이제 또 뉴스 하나 나온 거는
어쨌거나 파업에 대비해서 웨이퍼
생상량을 조금 줄여 가면서 어
가동률을 좀 줄여가고 있다라는게 또
나와서 아 그래도 물량 충격은 좀
있겠네라고 하는 또 소식도 있기
때문에
>> 어쨌거나 이제 삼성 파업 문제가
깔끔하게 해결돼야 좀 안개가 좀 거실
것 같습니다. 근데 완전한 파업까지는
안 간다면 저는 물량이 조금 줄어도
괜찮다. 왜냐면 그 가격이 더 빠르게
상승할 거
>> 그 정도라면어
충분히 흡수할 수 있는 능력이 있다고
좀 보고 있고요. 뭐 실적에 대한
걱정도 크게 하고 있지 않습니다.
>> 네. 상황은 아무튼 예의 주시하시되
자신감을 좀 가져도 좋다 이렇게 보고
있습니다. 지금
>> 좋습니다. 두 번째 저희가 주목한
뉴스는 자 저희가 얘기를 안 할 수가
없는데요. 스타벅스 얘기예요.
>> 네. 아하. 네. 오늘도 얼마나
화나실 건지 감도 안 잡힙니다.
>> 근이 화가 많으시더라고. 놀랬습니까?
예.
>> 아니요. 우리 이성적으로 이성적으로이
문제를 판단해 보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 뭐 여러분들 내용은 다 아시는
거고요. 어제 5.18 민주화 운동인
날에 스타벅스가 탱크데이를 했고
5.18에서 쉽게 말해서 저 뭐요?
텀블러를 판다. 세트를 판다 이런
거잖아요. 근데 이제 이름을
탱크데이로 했고
>> 또 옆에 뭐죠? 책상을 그게 있었죠.
>> 예. 책상의 탁
>> 책 탁이라는 것도 있어서예
>> 5.18 민주화 운동에 대해서 이제
편의 논란 있고 박총철 열사에 대해서
조롱하는 거죠. 사실 저에게는 예죠.
그래서 여러분들 이제 많이 내용을
아시는데 자 내용을 보면서 제가 이제
생각한게 있거든요. 뭐냐면
>> 계속 이걸 반복하고 있다.
>> 네.
>> 이유가 있다. 뭐냐면
>> 어 치료가 안 됐기 때문이요.
>> 어 그거 그러면 어떤 치료가 가장
중요하냐? 금융
>> 치료예요네. 그렇죠. 지금 종영진
회장은 금융 치료가 안 돼 있어요.
그러니까 저 잘못을 계속 반복하고
있거든요. 그걸 이재명 대통령도 계속
얘기하잖아요.
>> 기업들의 변화를 진짜 변화를
일으키려면 어떻게 해야 된다? 금융
치료해 줘야 된다.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 진짜이 스타벅스 코리아는요.
그리고 신세계나 이마트는 제가 볼 때
금융 치료를 해 줘야 돼요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 어 그래서 스타벅스 코리아를 잠깐
살펴보면
>> 2025년 기준으로 스타벅스 한국의
매장수는 2,700 2077개예요.
>> 네.
>> 음. 중국 다음으로 전 세계에서
그러니까 미국 중국 다음으로 전
세계에서 가장 매장이 많고요. 한국
국민당 10만 명당 매장이네 개가
있어요. 이건 뭐냐면 미국으로 많은
매장이에요.
>> 그만큼 사실은 스타벅스 코리아는
한국에서 잘되고 있다는 얘기예요.
네.
>> 지난해 매출 기준으로 해서 3조원
넘게 매출을 일으키고 있는데이
스타벅스 코리아의 지분 관계를 보면
67.5%가 이마트를 갖고 있고
나머지 32.5%는 %는 싱가포르
투자청인 GIC가 보유한 것으로 일단
파악이 됩니다. 네.
>> 자, 그러면이 회사는 한국에서 막
장사를 하고 한국 국민들한테 이렇게
쉽게 말해서 커피를 팔고 있는데 어,
오일파에 대한 편매했다. 그러면
어떻게 금융 치료를 해야 됩니까?
>> 당연히 불매로 간다.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 예. 그래야 고쳐질 거 아닙니까?
그래서 저희는 스타벅스 코리아 불매
운동을 12시 만나에서 강력하게
하고자 합니다.
>> 어 그래서 저희 슬로원들
만들었는데요.
스타벅스 가지 말고 주식 사자.
>> 어떻습니까?
>> 제가 딱 생각해 봤는데요. 그 스피
한 잔값으로
>> 코스닥 ETF에 한 주 살 수 있어.
>> 코스닥 많이 못 올랐죠.
>> 어차피 쓰는 돈으로 생각하고 괜찮죠.
네.
>> 그래서 매일 한 주씩 산다. 자,
스타벅스 코리아는 이제 안 간다.
스타벅스는 어, 절대 안 갑니다.
>> 네.
>> 앞으로 가려면 여기 들어오지 마세요.
>> 스타벅스 가지 말고 주식 사자.
>> 그러니까 왜 안 고쳐지냐면 맨날 이런
것들에서 얘기하고 잘못됐다고 말만
하지. 행동을 안다니까 안 고쳐지는
거예요. 그래서 이번에 강력하게
한다. 두 번째는 뭐냐면 제가 뭘
했냐면 스타벅스 본사에다 메일을
보냈습니다.
어 거기 주요 임원들하고요. 그다음에
어 언론 관계 뭐 프라이스 센터
그다음에 인베스터 관리하는 IR 쪽
메일을 자게 다 보냈어요.
>> 아 이메일을 보내셨어요?
>> 네. 이메일을 직접 보냈고 이제
답변을 기다릴 텐데
>> 이메일의네 가지가 제가 말했습니다.
첫 번째네.
>> 스타벅스 코리아가 이런 엄청난 일을
저질렀다.이
>> 캠페인이 어떻게 승인되고 실행됐는지
철저한 독립 조사를 본사해서 해라.
네.
>> 두 번째는
>> 마케팅 담당자와 그 의외에 대한
임원들에 대해서 엄중한 책임을 물어야
된다. 세 번째 근본적으로 이런
문제가 계속 일어나니까 라이센스에
대해서 고민해 봐라. 네. 그니까
스타벅스가 너네 장사 계속 이제
신세계나 이마타고 손 끊어라. 이거
이거를 제가 요청한 거예요. 말한
거예요.네 번째 유사한 사건의 제발을
방지하기 위해서 구체적으로 검증
가능한 조치를 마련할 것. 네. 제가
이런 내용으로 해서 메일을 보냈고
한번 답을 기다려 보겠습니다. 제가
마지막에 어떤 말도 했냐면
이번 사건으로 대한민국 소비자들
사이에서 광범위한 공분이 커지고 있고
스타벅스에 대한 불매 운동이
전국적으로 시행될 거다.
>> 그래서 너네 조심하라 이거예요.
>> 그다음에 한국 국민들은 스타벅스
본사가이 사안에
>> 걸맞는 무게감으로 대응할 거며 말로만
수습할 건지 우리가 끝까지
지켜보겠다. 이렇게 매일 보냈습니다.
>> 네.
>> 한번 답변을 기다려 보고. 아,
그니까 제가 계속 강조하는 건 뭐냐면
이런 문제가 생겼을 때 왜 계속
반복되느냐?
>> 음.
>> 행동하지 않기 때문이요.
>> 네.
>> 그러니까 우리가 진짜 행동한다.
>> 듣다 보니까 널리널리 알려야 될 거.
>> 널리 널리요. 그래서 여러분들도 다
메일 보내세요. 저희가 내일 메일
주소서 다 답변 안 오면 메일 주소서
알려 드릴테니까 우리가 저 임원들
메일 주소서 다 파악했거든. 계속
보낼 겁니다.
>> 저희 같은 MG 소비자들은요.이
제품을 그냥 사는게 아니고 브랜드
태도까지 보거든요.
>> 특히나 이런 역사 외곡에 대해서는 좀
기본 교향이 부족한 부분이기 때문에
어 생각해 보니까 널리널리
>> 지금 민원을 넣어야 되는 것이
아닌가?
>> 네. 단순히 이제 화만낼 문제가
아니고요.
>> 어, 법적인 어떤 어, 페널티도 제가
볼 때는 제도적으로 있어야 될 거
같고이
>> 자본 시장 내에서 또 여기 관계돼
있는 그죠
>> 설량한 예를 들면 노동자분들도 계실
거고
>> 주주도 있을 거고요. 또 그게 좋은
회사인 줄 알고 마음 편하게
소비하려고 했던 소비자들에게 다 이게
사실은 영향이 가능거든요.
>> 예. 경제 내에서도 어 혼 나야
돼요.
>> 맞습니다. 그러니까 어 맨날 그러니까
문제 제기하고 거기서 끝나지 않는다.
액션까지 해야 된다. 행동을 해야
세상이 바뀔 거 아닙니까? 그래서
>> 어 이걸 우리가 계속 할 할 거고요.
불매 운동도 우리가 계속 할 겁니다.
어 그리고 메일도 계속 보낸다.
그리고 여러분들이 한번 댓글에 달아
주세요. 우리가 뭘 또 더할 수
있는지.
>> 예. 그래서 함께해서 진짜
>> 쉽게 말해서 고쳐야죠.
>> 어. 잘못을 했으면. 맞.
>> 잘못해서 그냥 말만 하고 앞으로
잘해야지 하니까 계속 그러는 거
아니에요. 네.
>> 예. 이번에 한번 본대를 보여 줘야
됩니다. 힘을 보여 줘야 돼요.
>> 네.
>> 코스닥 ETF 사자.
>> 그죠? 스타벅스
그거 맛있어요. 근데
>> 그거는 뭐 노려할 왜냐면 또 어
>> 왜 우리 거 그거 거기까지가 이러면
또 우리 피곤하니까
>> 제가 볼 때 오늘 주가 빠지는 것도
정용지 때문이야.
>> 예. 맞아. 어제 사실은 그러니까
아까 좋은 말씀 해주셨는데요.
스타벅스 지분 관계는 어떻게 되냐면
사실은 이제 신세계 이마트가
>> 거의 한 70% 육박하게 갖고 있고
나머지는 이제 재문적 투자자예요.
싱가폴 거기는 이제 빼고 사실상
그러니까 이마트 겁니다. 어 근데 왜
스타벅스 이름을 쓰고 있지? 걔네들이
이제 라이선스 계약을 해 가지고요.
이미지 로고 이런 거 쓰도록 하고
로열티 받고요. 그다음에 스타벅스
경영 방침 그다음에 원두 이런 걸
이제 스타벅스 본사랑 계약해서 쓰고
있는 거거든요. 예. 그러니까 뭐
우리 기업이다 보시면 되고 우리가
혼낼 수 있어요.
>> 중분요. 그리고 이제 스타لى폭스
본사에서 좀 더 도와주 도와주면 좀
더 변화의 속도가 빠를 수 있겠죠.
>> 근데 스타스 본사들도 조금 아시아랑
우리 좀 무시하긴 하는데 걔네들도
이참에 동시 혼날 준비를 좀 해야 될
것 같아.
>> 알겠습니다. 알겠습니다. 계속 저희가
메일 보내고 아니면 전화라도 막 계속
하겠습니다.
>> 네네. 자, 저희가 어 시장이 좀
흔들리고 있는데 시장에 관련된 주요
뉴스 정리해 드렸고요. 어,이 정도로
마무리하고
우리 권하우산님 오늘 첫 번째
오셨는데 제가 화만 내서 죄송합니다.
어떠셨어요?
>> 보통 때 같으면 원래 이런 사람이
아니거든요라고 하는데 원래 이런
사람이
>> 아, 네. 저는 뭐 애청자로서 종종
봤습니다. 눈물 돌리시는 것도 보고
얼굴이 막 빨개 가지고 얼굴
풀락하시는 것도 봤고 그러니까 오늘
장 같은 경우에 좀 빠져서 제가 사실
아 대타로 나왔는데 하필 오늘 장이
너무 빠지네라고 해서 조금 겁을
먹었거든요. 근데 해석을 좀 잘하면
좋은 장인 거 같다라는
>> 네. 권나운 선님 나오자마자 지금
반등 중이에요. 이렇게요.
지금네 낙폭을 회복해 가고 있습니다.
계속해서 올라가기 기대하겠습니다네.
오늘 시간 너무 감사하고요. 저희가
이렇게 마무리하고 두 번째 코너로
이어가도록 하겠습니다.
>> 저는 시장에 이렇게 변동성이 클수록
원칙으로 한번 들어가 보고자 해요.
그래서 두 번째 시간에서는 네.
여러분들이 그동안 저희한테에 많은
질문을 해 주셨어요. 그 질문에
답하는 시간 AS 센터라고 해서이 두
번이어서 해 드리고요. 그리고
국민성장 펀드에 대해서 많은 분들이
또 질문이 많으셔서 그 부분에 대해서
같이 이야기해 보도록 하겠습니다. 두
번째 시간에는 우리에
>> 권다영커 님이 또 함께 해 주십니다.
여러분 끝까지 함께 해 주시고요.
어, 그리고 이어가 보도록
하겠습니다.
예, 여러분 12시에 만나요.
함께하고 계십니다. 이번 코너는
오랜만에에 새로 돌아왔습니다. 12시
AS 센터를 한번 열어 볼까 합니다.
>> 네. 네.
>> 아, 저희가 처음에는 최소형 PD하고
같이 했는데요.
>> 맞아요. 첫방에서.
>> 네. 근데 최소형 PD는 저희가 못
불러오고 있어요.
>> 아씨. 공장이님이
네건 조건이죠. 동접자 10만을
넘어야 최성을 쓸 수 있다.
>> 아, 근데 왜 이렇게 어려운 겁니까?
>> 10만의 벽이 너무 덥다.
>> 네. 그래서 지금 최성피디가 못
았어요. 예.
>> 아, 네. 알겠습니다. 저희 신만을
한번 기다려 보고 옆에 또
권다영이콘님
>> 네. 네. 음,
>> 맞습니다.
>> 오늘 저희는
어떤 걸 해 볼까요? 오늘 사실
저희가 방송 중에도 그렇고 방송
끝나고 나서 댓글에도 여쭤 보시는
것들이 되게 많아요. 근데 이제
매일매일 뉴스도 소화야 되고 뭐 장도
봐야 되고 이러다 보니까 그걸 다
답변을 못 드린 거 같아서 특별하게
AS 센터를 좀 열어 볼까 합니다.
>> 근데 굉장히 중요한 거 같아요.
왜냐면 질문을 많이 해 주시는데
거기에서 중요한 또 질문들이
있습니다.
>> 맞아요.
>> 예. 근데 그 답을 해 주면서 많은
분들이 또 투자하는데 도움을 받을 수
있으니까.
>> 그 저희는 또이 소통을 예. 생명으로
삼는 사람들 아닙니까? 예. 우리는
또 이게 덕장님들이 올려 주신 질문들
그냥 넘어가지 않습니다.
>> 모아 모아서 이렇게 다 풀어드립니다.
>> 욕도 다 봐요.
네.
>> 욕도 다봐요. 한 분이 계속 욕을
>> 누구야?
좋습니다. 그러면 일단 우리 국민
투자자분들이 어떤 질문을 했는지 우선
>> 권다영 앵커 님한테 들어온 질문이
있어요.
>> 제가 그러면 우리 서로서로 각자에게
올라온 질문을 질문하는 해 볼게요.
일단 건다영카님에게 첫 번째 질문
갑니다. 자, 평소에 잘 알려 주시는
개인과 외국인 기관의 수급. 흠
>> 궁금한데 이건 도대체 어디서 보고
투자할 때 어떻게 활용하는
건가요?라고
>> 질문을 주셨네요.
>> 네. 일단은 저는 기본적으로
>> 어 시장을 볼 때 HTS라고 해서 홈
트레이딩 시스템이라고 이야기를 하죠.
그래서 증권사에 내가 있잖아요. 그를
연 증권사에는 모두 대부분 HTS가
있습니다. 그래서 만약에 내가 뭐 어
뭐 키움 증권 쓴다, 삼성증권 쓴다
들어가면 다 다운을 받으실 수
있어요. 그래서 거기서 매매를 직접
진행을 하실 수도 있고요. 꼭 거기가
아니더라도 포털 사이트에 요즘 증권
탭들 되게 많잖아요. 거기서 뭐라고
보면 되냐면 투자자별 매매 동향이라는
것이 있습니다.음. 네. 거기에
개인들이 뭘 사는지 외국인 기관이
어떻게 사고파는지에 대해서 확인을
해볼 수가 있다라고 말씀을 드릴 수
있겠고요. 음. 그리고 투자에는
어떻게 활용을 하냐라고 하신 어 말주
질문을 주셨는데 그때 말씀
주셨잖아요. 외국인들이 어떻게
매매하는지 우리가 좀 알아야 된다라고
하셨는데 외국인들이 사면서 시장이
오를 때에는
진짜 외국인들이 무슨 종목을 사는지
되게 자세하게 열어 봐야 됩니다.
>> 맞아요. 중요하죠.
>> 예. 왜냐면 말씀주신 대로 외국인이
오늘 A라는 종목을 뭐 100만 원
어이 사기로 했어요.
>> 그러면 가격과 상관없이이 100만
원을 다 채우게 되잖아요.
>> 사는 데는 이유가 있을 것이고 그
결정이 나온 이유를 우리는 정확하게는
모르지만
>> 음
>> 뭐 그들이 똑똑하니까 그렇게 결정하지
않았겠습니까? 그래서 가격 상관없이
그렇게 사는 종목들에 대해서는 우리가
좀 관심 있게 봐야 한다라고 주로
이야기를 하고요. 기관 같은 경우는
굉장히 많은 주체들이 있습니다.
금융, 투자, 보험, 투신, 기타
금융, 은행, 연기금 사모 펀드가
있는데 우리가 주로 보는 쪽은
연기금과 금융 투자일 것 같습니다.
근데 저희 방송에서 연기금에 대해서는
뭐 워낙 많이 말씀을 드렸고
>> 음
>> 금융 투자에 대해서는 요거는 제가 두
분께 조금 더 이제 현업에 계셨으니까
여쭤보고 싶은게 이게 사실 ETF
수급이 요즘에는 더 많은 거
아닌가요?
>> 훨씬 많죠. 가장 크죠.
>> 네. 그래서이 ETF 수급을 그래서
진짜 금융 투자가 산다. 기관이
산다라기보다는 개인이 산다라고
해석하는게 맞는 거죠. 요즘에는
>> 맞습니다. 어. 그리고 그게 그니까
ETF도 두 종류가 있으니까 하나는
뭐냐면 일종에 그냥 자동으로 시가총의
군위별로 사는 자산이 배분되는 또
하나는 액티브 ETF라고 그래서 자산
운용사가 어떤 전략을 갖고 ETF를
종목을 이제 구성하는 건데 지금
한국의 대부분 ETF는 어 쉽게
말해서 코스피 200 ETF를 사면
그 시가총액 어 배분 분위별로 그냥
사기 때문에 어 그냥 개인진이 산다고
어 보면 됩니다.
>> 네.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 첫 번째 질문 잘 정리해 주셨고요.
제가 볼 때는 아주 좋은 말씀인데
각자 있는 프로그램을 통해서 보셔도
되지만 진짜 포털 예.
>> 네. 그냥 포털에 내땡 뭐 이런데 뭐
>> 주식 증권 이렇게 친다.
>> 증권 교자 뭐 쓰세요? 저는 여러 개
쓰긴 하는데 주로 보는 HTS는 저는
키움을 많이 쓰고요. 거기랑 아
이게이
>> 뭐 약간 광고의 느낌이 나서
>> 아 저 광고 건님 광고 봤습니다.
>> 아 그러니까 이게 또 HTS마다 되게
특점들이 있어요. 그래서 어 제가
저는 KB에도 있고 계좌가 많은데
>> 아 다 깔아 놓겠다. 깔
>> KB 같은 경우는 뉴스가 좀 강해요.
그래서 계약을 한 그 포털 매체가
있고 이래서 해외 뉴스를 AI로 자동
번역해서 올려주는 이런 것들이 좀
있고요.
>> 키움 같은 경우는 템마다 볼 수 있는
것들이 꽤 많습니다. 그래서
실시간으로 체크되는 것들이 좀 빠르고
뭐 대신 증권에서는 시가 총액
순서대로 보는 것, 숫자 써 있는 것
이런 것들이 보기 편하다 이렇게
표현을 해서 이게 약간 취향을 사실은
타요.
>> 네. 음.
>> 본인이어
투자하는 스타일에 따라서
>> 근데 사실은 이제 좀 스마트한
투자자가 되시려면 회사마다 사실 그
정성을 들여서 굉장히 사실은 노력해서
그 모든 메뉴들을 만들어 놓는
거거든요.
>> 그리고 이제 뭐 1년 2년 지나고
나면 또 개편도 많이 하고 거기 있는
기능들이 사실 굉장히 많은데맞
>> 그런 그냥 아유 나는 사고 팔고만
할래 말고 그 다양한 기능들을 좀
들어가서 연습해 보시는 것도 도움이
되세요.
>> 재밌어요.
재투자
그니까 증권사들이 거기에 또 투자도
많이 하기 때문에 아마 도움이 많이
되신 거 같아. 그리고 아까이 매수
주체별 동양를 찾아보라는 것도 좋은
말씀이시고 우리 이제 아가님들
입장에서는 외국인 오케이, 개인
오케이, 기관음 했는데 기관 안에
말이 기관이지 여러 다양한게 또 각이
숨어 있더라. 요것도 이제 아마
아셨을 것 같아요. 좋은 설
>> 그리고 요런 걸 보셔야 약간 보는
눈이 넓어집니다. 그건 맞는 거
같아요. 네. 그럼 이제 두 번째
문으로 넘어갈게요. 권다영에커님 늘
좋은 뉴스 전해 주셔서 감사합니다.
>> 투자자 개인이 습관하면 좋을 매일
아침 꼭 챙겨야 하는 뉴스나 확인해야
하는 지표 같은게 있을까요?
>> 네. 저는 그니까이 HTS나
MTS라고 해서 모바일로도 볼 수
있잖아요. 거기에 뉴스이 따로
있습니다. 거기에 제가 이제
키워드들을 저장을 해 놓고 매일매일
이제 검색을 하는 키워드가 있는데 두
가지를 좀 말씀을 드리면 좋을 것
같아요.
>> 오, 이건 꿀팁이다.
>> 어, 계장전 주요 이슈 점검이라는
키워드로 검색을 하시면 네. 그래서
장전 세 글자만 검색을 해도
뜨거든요. 이게 매일 아침 한 8시
반쯤 올라와요. 그래서 미국장이
어떻게 마감이 됐는지, 원자지 어떻게
마감이 됐는지, 어, 경제 지표들
밤에 뭐가 나왔는지, 그리고 어,
오늘 우리 장에 있을 만한 뉴스들을
쫙 클리핑을 해 줍니다. 좋다.
>> 이건 영화밀 같은데.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 제가 우리 주아가님들을 위해서
다 네. 아, 그래서
>> 기업 산업별로도 해주고요. 매크로
이슈도 해 주고요. 오늘 일정에
대해서도 해 주고요. 그래서 기사가
되게 많아요. 근데 이거 하나만 봐도
계장전에 볼건 다 봤다. 요렇게 보실
수 있어서 요거를 보고요. 한 가지
키워드를 더 추천을 드리면
스케줄이라고 검색을 하시면
>> 네. 스케줄.
>> 스케줄. 오늘의 이슈 테마 스케줄.
내일의 이슈, 테마, 스케줄 이런게
뜹니다. 그래서 오늘 무슨 일들이
있는지 정말 자세하게 나옵니다.
그래서 오늘도 보니까
스케줄을 여기서 어 43개의
아이템을 알려 줬어요. 그래서 어떤
종목이 추가 상장을 한다. 뭐 보호
예수 해제, 경제 지표는 뭐가
나옵니다. 뭐 요런 것들 있잖아요.
그런 것들을 싹 정리를 해 주기
때문에 이런 것들 보시면 좋을 거
같고요. 그럼 말씀 나온 김에 이번
주 일정 한번 스케줄 간단하게네
>> 그렇죠. 제가 이번 주 스케줄 좀
체크를 해 드리도록 하겠습니다.
그래서 요런 것들 보시면서 또 주말
되면은 다음 주 스케줄이 이렇게
떠요.
>> 그런 것들 정리를 좀 해 보도록
하겠습니다. 아, 일단 한일정상 회담
개최가 5월 19일 화요일 오늘
열리게 됩니다. 아, 미국에서는 잠정
주택 판매 지수 발표가 되고요. 또
화요일 밤에 중요한게 구글의 아이오
기조 연설이 시작이 됩니다. 일정 다
말씀드리고 구글 i는 조금 더 추가
말씀을 드릴게요. 수요일에는 중국에서
LPR 금리 결정이라고 써 있는데
중국의 실질 금리 진 어 중국에서
쓰는 금리라고 생각을 해 보면 될 것
같습니다. 또 수요일에는 푸틴
대통령이 방중을 음하게 됩니다. 또
중요한 것 FOMC 의사록이 공개가
되고요. 무엇보다도 엔비디아 실적이
미국 현재 시간으로 5월 20일
우리나라 시간으로는 5월 어 21일
오전 6시에 발표가 될 예정입니다.
그리고 목요일로 가면 우리나라의 4월
생산자 물가 지수랑 수출입 통계
발표가 되고요. 아 모르겠습니다만
아직 삼성전자 총파업 원래는 예정이
되어 있는 일정입니다. 그리고
금요일로 가면음 국민 참여형 국민
성장 펀드가 이날부터 출시가 되고요.
우리나라에서는 5월 소비자 신뢰 지수
발표가 될 예정이라는 거 함께 체크해
보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 간략하게만 출려도 사실 이번 주도 또
일정이 빡빡해요. 예. 그럼 일단
투자자분들께서 그래도 저걸 다 볼 수
없으니까
>> 딱 두 개만 골라 주세요.
>> 어 딱 두 개만 고르자면 첫 번째는
아 어려운 미션을 주시네. 네.
첫번째는 뭐 당연히 비디아의 실적
아닐 저도 그렇게 생각을
해볼 수 있겠습니다. 비디아
>> 비디아 형 이번에 좀 어
>> 제순왕 형 그죠
>> 통닭 먹고 힘든 내야 돼요 지금
>> 지금 통닭도 먹고 중국 갔다 왔는데
뭐가 없어 가지고 지금 약간 걱정이
되는데 이번 엔비디아 실적을 통해서
결국에는 그거 보고 싶은 거거든요.
AI 수요가 진짜 견조한지 앞으로도
견조할 건지 이거 두 개를 좀 보시면
좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 네. 미국뿐만 아니라 전 세계 투심에
지금 제일 중요한 예. 이번 주에 그
중요한 지표가 될 것 같아요.
>> 네. 그리고 한 가지만 더 덧붙여서
말씀을 드리비디아 하나만 더 덧붙여서
말씀을 드리면 엔비디아가 최근 세 개
분기 동안 실적 발표하고 나서 계속
빠졌어요. 근데 다행인 것은
엔비디아가이 세계 분기 동안 실적은
좋았거든요. 그날 코스피 올랐을까요?
내렸을까요?
>> 올랐어요. 올랐어.
>> 세계 분기 연속 엔비디아가 실적
발표한 날은 코스피가 올랐습니다.
네. 맞아요. 그래서 제가 말씀드린
거예요. 엔비디아 팔고 그
>> 엔비디아 팔고 삼성전자 사라 얘들아.
네.
>> 어 하고요. 그리고 구글에 아이오
행사 이게 도대체 뭔데 왜 보라는
거야라고 질문 주실 것 같아.
>> 아 그게 넘버 2인가요? 그게 아마
넘버튼 거 2라고 저는 어 하고
싶은데 왜냐면 구글 아이오 개발자
컨퍼런스라고 해서 미국 서부 시간
기준으로 5월 19일부터 시작이
됩니다. 어 메인 테마가 전면적인
AI화라고 하고요. 컴퓨터 컴퓨팅
파워의 극대화한 재미나이 4.0이
발표될 거라고 합니다. 그러니까
지금이 채집피틴이 아니면 뭐 클로드이
재미나인이 누가 누가 더 잘하냐 계속
경쟁을 하고 있잖아요. 그래서 또이
>> 재미이가 또 엄청 좋으면은 움직일
종목들이 또 따로 있거든요. 그런
것들 함께 좀 체크해 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 네. 저는 사실 FOMC
의사로 좀 궁금해요. 지금 하도
국채가 날리고 그 금리가 날리니까
도대체 연준 의원들이 저번에 어떤
생각을 했는지 그 힌트를 좀 하고
싶어요. 네. 저는 같은 날 그 국채
입찰도 중요해 보도 중요해요.
>> 수요가 많아야 금리가 좀 안정되고
떨어질 수 있는데 음
>> 음
>> 지금 30년물 기준으로는 입찰가
자체가 5%를 넘었기 때문에 이게
아예 추세를 변화시키는 것이다라고 할
수 있는데 만약에 20년물도 그러면
약간 부담스럽겠죠.
>> 그죠? 굳어질 수 있으니까.
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 일정까지 어떻게 파악하는지. 우리
곤대
>> 진짜 꿀팁을 주셨네요.
>> 네. 진짜요? AS를 해 주셨습니다.
이번에는 박시동 대표님한테도 많은
질문이에 들어왔습니다. 외모
질문이겠죠.
>> 어쩜 사람이 그렇게 귀엽나 뭐 이런
거 아니겠어요?
>> 똑같고
싶
>> 그만하고 싶
자 그러면 권양커 님이 대신해서
질문을 드려 보겠습니다네
>> 첫 번째 질문입니다. 계란을 한
바구니에 담지 마라. 아,
>> 분산투자해야 한다라고 하는데 어느
정도로 많은 종목에 분산 투자를 해야
할까요라는이
질문 참 많이 저희가 봤는데요.
결론부터 말씀드리겠습니다. 좀 과격한
편소해 주시고요. 저는 이렇게
말씀드려요. 분산 투자 쓰레기입니다.
아니, 요렇게 세게 말씀해 드려야
조금 경관심을 가지시더라고요.
맞아요. 기억하시더라고요. 원래는
이제 분산 투자는 사실은 원칙적인
의미에서 말하면 교과서적으로 말하면
이자산과 이자산이 간섭이 없어야
돼요.
>> 그러니까 사실은 주식
>> 그다음에 주식과 전혀 상관없는 또는
반대로 움직일 수 있는 채권 또는
그것과 이거 다 이금 금융 시장이니까
또 그거랑 상관없는 예를 들면 대체
자산 뭐 금이든 부동산이든 뭐
광물이든 예를 들어서 아니면 뭐
미술품이든 이렇게 아예 간섭이 없는
자산으로 나눠야 서로 영향을 안
받거든요. 그렇게 하는게 원래는
분산이에요. 사실은요.
>> 진정한 분산.
>> 그렇죠. 근데 그런 거를 할 정도의
자산 규모가 안 되시면은 사실은 그
정도까지 고려할 필요가 없다. 근데
우리가 보통 얘기하는 거는 나 주식할
거야. 근데 주식 안에서 종목을 여러
개를 나눠 가지고이 종목이 오르면 저
종목이 떨어져도 괜찮고 저거 떨어지면
이게 올르면 되겠지. 이런 식으로
이제 분산 개념을 좁혀서 생각하시는데
저는 그런 협의의 분산에 대해서
쓰레기다 이렇게 말씀드리는 거예요.
>> 어, 사실은 왜 우리가 분산 투자를
하냐면
>> 위험을 분산하려고 하는 거거든요.
그런데 이제 제가 대부분 만나는 우리
보통 사람들, 보통의 이제 개인
투자자들은 가슴에 손으로 얹고 생각해
보세요. 이렇게 말씀드려요. 여러분은
분산할 위험이 없어요. 이렇게
말씀드립니다.
예. 저 투자금 1천만 원인데요.
그게 뭐가 위험합니까? 제가 이렇게
말씀드려요.
자, 그래서 웬만한 규모에 계신 개인
투자자분들은 나는 꼭 분산을 해야
돼. 여러 종목을 해야 돼라는 강박을
가지실 필요가 없다. 이렇게
말씀드려요. 그럼 그 웬만한 기준이
뭔데? 제가 그냥 임의로 정해
드립니다. 네.
>> 2억 밑으로 분산 얘기하지도 마세요.
>> 음.
>> 진짜 그렇게 말씀드려요.
>> 음. 물론 이제 개별적으로 보면
2억은 큰 돈인데 이렇게 말씀하실 수
있지만이 주식 세계 안에서는 사실
상대적으로 보면 그렇게 큰 돈
아니거든요. 그래서 2억 정도가 될
때까지는 꼭 나눠야지라고 하는
강박적인 분산을 생각하시지 마시라.
>> 그러면 뭘 생각해야 되냐? 위험
대신에 수익을 생각하시라. 음산투자
대신에 수익을 향한 집중자를 하시라
이렇게 말씀드려요.
>> 그래서 한
>> 2억 정도까지 규모가 올라갈 때까지는
분산하기보다는
종목 내지는 여섯 종목으로 종목을
좁히시라. 음를 들어
이렇게 하셔도 된다. 저 그렇게
말씀드려요. 왜냐면 그렇게 해야
사실은
>> 수익이 많이 나고
>> 쉽게 말하면 돈이 됩니다.
>> 그런데 예를 들어서 한 뭐 3천만 원
2천만 원 투자하시는데 종목을 막
30개씩 쪼개 가지고 한 주짜리를 막
20개씩 들고 계세요.
>> 그런 거는 돈이 안 된다. 실질적으로
분산 효과도 없다. 돼서 아예 원칙적
의미의 분산 저 어의 개념을 버리시라
이런 건 아니지만 적절한 규모가 될
때까지는 수익이 더 중요하기 때문에
대여섯 종목으로 집중하시는데 신경
쓰시기고 신경 쓰시고 강박적 의미의
분산에 예 연연해하지 않으셔도 좋겠다
이런 말씀을 좀 드립니다.
>> 네.
>> 저만의 팁이에요. 네.
>> 그러니까 유독 한국의 주식 시장에서이
결란을 계란을 한 바구에 담지 말라는
말이 굉장히 많이 알고 계시더라고요.
>> 네. 한 30년 전에 무슨 CF에서
나와서 그래요.
>> 아, 그래요?
>> 아, 무슨 펀드 팔면서?
>> 예예. 바이코리아 시절에 나왔어요.
그래서 뭐
>> 약간 그 느낌이 뿌자되세요?
아까 계속 남은 그런 느낌이군요.
아, 맞아요. 맞아요. 그러면서 많은
분들이
>> 아, 그래 계란 한 바구에 담으면 안
되지. 근데 저는 개인적으로 이런
생각이 든다.
>> 계란을 한 바구니에 담지 말라는 말은
뭐냐면 바구니를 여러 개 담으라는
거잖아요.
>> 네.
근데 종목을 여러 개 사는 건 계란을
여러 개 그러니까 예를 들어서 뭐
하얀 결란, 노란 결란, 빨간 결란이
얘기를 하는 거 아니에요.
>> 맞아요. 제 말씀이 그 말씀이에요.
그러니까 주식 안에서의 분사는 굳이
의미가 크지 않다.
>> 맞아요. 어 차라리 저는 그래서
바구니를 그러면 다른 방울리에
담아라는 말은
>> 방법을 얘기하는게 아닐까?
>> 방법
>> 방법을 달리하거나
아니면은
>> 뭐라 할까? 그래서 투자 방법이
중요한 거 아닐까? 그런 생각
개인적으로 좀 하긴 했어요.
>> 네. 맞습니다.
>> 두 번째 질문으로가 볼까요? 두 번째
질문입니다. 삼성전자를 사려고 보니
삼성전자 우라고 있는데 이건 뭔가요?
그리고 이건 왜 더 싼가요? 그럼 싼
맛에 더 사도 되는 걸까요라는
질문입니다.
>> 삼성전자 우 여기서 우가 좀 귀엽게
들리는데요. 우
>> 그렇게 읽어야 되는 거 같아요.
그죠? 예. 우자. 우. 이렇게.
네.
>> 우. 아니요.
>> 네. 맞습니다. 여기.
>> 아. 우가 되게 다양하
>> 다양합니다. 예.
>> 아, 그러니까 우리말이 재밌어요.
>> 그니까요.
>> 이제 여기서 우는 이제 우선주고요.
그럼 우가 아닌 건 뭐야? 보통주
이렇게 보시면 됩니다. 그래서 우
없는 건 그냥 보통주고요.
>> 우라고 걸려 있는 거는 우선한다는
건데 왜 우선하는 거냐? 뭔데? 네가
우선이야라고 할 때 배당을 우선해서
준다. 이런 의미에. 그러니까 어
다른 사람보다 내가 배당을 먼저 많이
특해로 받는 거야. 맞아요. 그래서
우선 준데 그럼 무조건 좋은 거네.
>> 또 그럴 순 없잖아요. 세상이.
그래서 너한테 특해를 주는 대신에 넌
뭘 하나 내놔. 그럼 난 뭘 내놔야
될까라고 할 때 의결권을 내놓는
거예요. 그니까 주총장에 못 가.
>> 문 열어. 내가 주주란 말이야. 이러
가면 아 우선주 주주시네요.
안녕하세요. 문을 안 열어 줘요.
쉽게 말하면. 그래서 의결권을
포기하는 대신에 배당을 줘라. 나
주청장에 갈 일 없다. 요렇게 만든
주가 우선주다. 이렇게 보시면
되는데요. 어 보통 이제 보통주보다
싸죠. 예. 그래서네. 어, 그
회사에 이익을 같이 공유하고 배당도
더 받으니까 나쁜 건 절대 아닙니다.
>> 투자하는 의미에서는 매력이 있습니다.
그런데 그럼에도 불구하고 의결권이
없기 때문에 하나의 핸드캡이 있다라고
생각해서 보통보다는 싸요. 그런데
얼마나 싸냐를 역사적 평균으로 쭉
보면 대충 그 종목별로 나와 있어요.
이게 보통주와 우선주의 역사적
괴리율이라고 하는 건데요. 예를 들어
보통주가 만 원이면 우선주는 늘
보니까 뭐 6,000원,
5만8,000원, 6만 원 요원리서
왔다 갔다 하더라. 그럼 아 대초한
60% 정도 되는구나 이런 역사적긴이
괴리율을 볼 수가 있거든요.
>> 그런데 이상하다. 늘 60% 정도
했는데 지금 보니까 5만 원인데 왜
쓸데없이 떨어져 있을까? 음균치할
수 있겠다. 요렇게 가끔 매력적인
구간에 걸려 있을 때가 있어요. 요럴
때는 특별히 좀 사도 좋겠다. 이런
말씀을 좀 드립니다.
>> 단,
>> 그럼 모든 우선주가 그렇게 좀 매력이
있을 수 있나 이렇게 생각할 수도
있는데요. 보통주를 더 많이
선호하시기 때문에 사실은 거래량이 좀
적거나 그럴 수가 있어요. 그래서
>> 유통 주식 수도 적죠.
>> 그렇죠. 네.
>> 그래서 우선주 중에서는 저 이렇게
말씀드리는데 가능하면 물량이 충분하고
거래량도 충분히 담보가 되고 그래서
어떤 통계를 대도 그게 유의미하게에
통계가 나오는 그런 종목 쉽게 말하면
사람들이 많이 사는 대기업
>> 우선음 거기를 먼저 검토하시면 그리고
그중에서 평소보다 괴류율이 좀 많이
벌어져 있다라고 하는 주식은 괜찮다
이렇게 좀 말씀드리겠습니다.
그러니까이 우자 보시고 처음 주식
투자하시는 분들이 가장 많이
생각하는게 뭐냐면 우량주예요.
>> 아,
>> 그래서 이건 삼성전자 우량주예요.
이렇게 질문 많이 하시고 그래서 이걸
사세요.
>> 우량주라고. 아. 아. 네.
>> 근데 여러분 우량주 아니고요.
>> 네.
>> 우선주.
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 자, 이번에는 이광수 대표님한테
질문을
>> 네.에
>> 온을 해 볼게요. 고님이 한번 말씀
주시죠. 네.
>> 음. 네. 제가 먼저 읽어 드릴게요.
어, 부부가 함께 투자를 하면서
문제가 생겼습니다.
>> 아,
>> 저는 고점에서 10% 빠지면 손절.
아내는 원금에서 10% 빠지면 손절.
이렇게 이야기를 하는데 손절 기준을
어떻게 잡아야 할까요라고 주셨네요.
>> 그러니까 일단은 손절면은 반드시
필요하다. 이유는 뭐냐면 말씀을
저희가 계속 드리지만 투자를 오랫동안
하기 위해서는 큰 손실을 막아야
돼요.
>> 네. 그러기 위해서는 반드시
여러분들이 어떤 종목에 투자하시건
손절매 가격은 가지고 있어야 된다.
주식을 처음 살 때부터 손절매 가격을
만들자.이 말씀. 그렇죠.
>> 그런데 많은 분들이 이런 또 반론을
제기하세요. 좋은 회사 그냥 주식
투자해서 오래 가지고 있으면 되는 거
아닌가? 그게 진짜 투자 아니야?
여러분 그 말도 맞습니다. 그런데
제가 말씀드리고 싶은 건 뭐냐면 좋은
회사와 좋 주가가 오르고 이건 또
별개 문제예요.
>> 예. 그러니까 여러분 엄청나게 좋은
회사도요. 주가가 빠지고요. 그리고
회복하지 못할 수도 있거든요. 그래서
우리는 투자를 하는 차원에서는
반드시이 손절에 대한 기준이 있어야
돼요. 이건 여러분들이 좋아하시는
월련법회 선생님도 있어요.
>> 손절한단 말이에요.
>> 그렇기 때문에 거기에 대해서 너무
>> 불편하게 생각하지 마시라. 왜 주식을
팔려는 거냐, 여러분? 주식은 파는
겁니다. 그래서 어쨌든 그래서 손절
기준을 가져가야 되는데 기준은
개개인별로 다룰 수 있죠. 네.
왜냐면 위험이 아까 말 박정 대표님이
말씀하신 것처럼 우의 위험의 정도가
사람마다 다르니까 나는 조금 더 뭐
20% 30% 빠져도 괜찮아 그러면
그렇게 하실 순 있어요. 근데 대부분
주식 투자를 처음 하시는 분들이
기준을 못 잡으니까 그걸 제가
10%라고 제시해 드리는 거예요.
근데 10%의 기준을 어떻게 잡냐면
>> 일단 첫 번째는 지수 대비에서 10%
이상 빠질 때 손절을 기준을
가져가겠다. 지수보다 더 많이
>> 네. 그렇죠. 그래서 코스피 지수가
2% 빠졌는데 내가 산 종목도 똑같이
2%가 빠졌습니다. 그러면 그때는
트럼프 욕하고 넘어갈게요.
>> 아, 네. 네.
>> 안 팔고.
>> 네.
>> 근데 코스피가 2% 빠졌는데 내가 산
주식이 12% 이상 빠졌어요. 그럼
10% 이상 빠진 거죠. 그때는
고민을 해야 돼요. 이제 손질 손절을
해야겠다는 그런 생각을 이제 가지셔야
된다는 거죠. 그런 기준을 이제 먼저
말씀드리고 두 번째는 근데 주가가
만약 오르잖아요. 주가가 오를 때는
손절의 기준도 달라지는 거예요.
그래서이 두 부분이 이제 논쟁이
있는게 아내분은 원금에서 10%
빠진다
>> 그러면 오를수록 사실 손절은 저 멀리
가는 거죠. 어 그러면 거의 안 못
팔게 돼요.이
>> 이익을 다 잃을 때까지 안 팔거든.
네. 그래서 말씀드리는게 뭐냐면
주가가 오르면 손절가도 오르는
거예요.
>> 따라서 그래서 만 원짜유 주식이 2만
원이 되면 아까처럼 단순하게
10%라고 정했다고 볼게요. 그러면
만 원에 샀을
때는 손절가가 9,000원이었죠.
근데 만 원이 2만 원으로 올랐을
때는 언제입니까? 만 만
>> 얼마예요? 8,000원이
18,000원이 손절가가 되는
거예요.
>> 그렇게 해서 이건 또 바뀔 수가
있죠. 내가 이제 이익을 많이
봤으니까. 아, 나는 30% 정도는
빠져도 돼.
>> 그러면 예를 들어서 어,
14,000원까지 이렇게 한번 보는
거고 여러분들이 어쨌든 중요한 건
손절의 범위를 무조건 정한다.
>> 네. 그리고 어 유연하게 범위를
조정해도 된다. 그리고 주가가 오르면
손절과도 당연히 오른다. 이렇게
생각하시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 그니까 그 손절이라는 의미를 꼭
마이너스라고 생각을 하셔서 두 분이
이런 논쟁을 하시는게 아닌가라는
생각도 드네요.
>> 맞아요. 맞아요. 맞아요. 그런데
주식 투자는 팔어야 이익이 돼요.
그래서 사는 것도 중요하지만 파는
것도 굉장히 중요해요.
>> 그 되게 기술이에요.
>> 맞습니다. 그래서 팔아야 또 이익이
되고 또 다른 투자를 할 수 있기
때문에 그러니까 우리가 언론이나
방송에서 보면 나 삼성전자 10년
갖고 있어서 대박 벌었다.
>> 음.
>> 그건 사실 결론적인 얘기예요.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 예. 만약에 돈 필요해서 중간에
팔았었어야 되는데 그게 2년 전이었다
그랬으면 무조건 손 손실이에요.
>> 네. 맞아요.
>> 그리고 삼성전자를 10년 동안 갖고
계신 분들 중에서 제가 단원 학원데
돈을 번 사람 많지 않아요.
>> 네.
>> 대부분 빠졌을 때 팔았겠지.
>> 네. 그렇죠. 예. 그 예. 그렇기
때문에 여러분들이 이런 어떤 그 파는
거에 대한 어 생각을 항상 가지셨으면
좋겠다라는 말씀을 드립니다.
>> 네. 두 번째 질문도 함께가 보도록
하겠습니다. 뒤늦게 12시요. 아
뒤늦게 12시에 만나요를 알게
됐어요. 돈이 없어서 반도체 주식을
못 샀는데 어떻해요?
>> 이런 분들 많아요? 요새 나만 못
사서 삼성전자 하이닉스. 아, 근데
저기서 반도체 주식은 돈이 없어서
반도체 주식을 못 샀다는 건
>> 비겁한 변명이죠.
>> 아니, 내 포트폴리오에 그 현금이
없었다라는 뜻일까요?
>> 그 저는 SK하이닉스였기 때문에 그런
거예요. SK 아닉스가 한 주에 막
200만 원, 100만 원 넘어가니까
>> 이제 못 산 건데. 예를 들어서
삼성전자는 30만 원이 안 되잖아요.
그거는 하실 수 있는 거고. 그니까
우리가 저게 저 질문을 듣고 제가 좀
당황했어요. 뭐냐면
>> 왜요?
>> 돈이 없어서 반도체 주식을 못 샀다.
저보고 어떻게 하는 거예요?
돈을 달라는 거예요? 뭐예요?
>> 아니 그니까 그 그거 아닐까요?
지금이라도
라라라고 질문하시
>> 그 질문이 명확하지 않아요.
>> 그러면 이제 그렇게 본다 앵커님처럼
그거죠. 너무 가격이 올라서 내가
반도체에 들어가기 좀
>> 두렵다 어렵다. 근데 제가 계속
말씀드리잖아요. 주식을 살 때는
>> 와을 보는 거다.음 그래서 지금
시점을 고민하면 너무 많이 올라서를
고민하지만 아 반도체 회사들이
좋아요. 제가 그래서 막 투자를
하자. 엄청 뭐이 말씀을 드리는게
아니라 모든 주식이 똑같습니다. 내가
살 때는 시점 가격을 보는게 아니라
그 회사가 가치가 충분하고 앞으로
가치가 더 좋아질 수 있다면
>> 어 왓을 사는 거예요. 그거 사시면
된다. 그래서 너무 늦은 건 없다.
지금 계속 뭐 삼성전자 10만 원
넘었을 때 아이고 많이 올랐네. 또
15만 원 올라서 많이 올랐네.
20만 원에서 많이 도대체 많이
올랐다는 기준은 뭐예요? 예. 저번에
살 껄껄 하다가 영원히 못 사죠.
>> 그렇죠. 그래서 오히려 어 시점에
대한 고민, 가격에 대해서 보는게
아니라
>> 어 난이 회사를 믿음이 믿음이 가네.
그리고 향으로 가치가 오를 수 있어.
실적이 좋아질 수 있어라고 하시면
사시는게 맞다.
>> 네. 이거 저의 직접적인 예를 좀
들어 드리면 좋을 거 같은데 저도
주식을 짧게 하지는 않았잖아요.
그래서 정말 예전에 SK닉스를 5만
원에 사서 9만 원에 바았던 경험이
있습니다.
>> 근데 그러고 나서 이제 SK닉스
30만 원, 40만 원 가니까 이거를
>> 손이 안 나가죠.
아, 가잖아요. 사람이 사람 마음이
그렇잖아요. 그럼에도 불구하고 이제
저는 매일이 엽을 하는 사람이다 보니
모르겠다 이러고 샀거든요. 그날부터
이제 룰루를 방송합니다.
>> 맞아요. 그걸 한번 끊어야 돼요.
>> 그 연습이 되면 이제는 어, 시점에
대한 고민보다도 그리고 가격을 보는게
아니라 그런 용기가 생기죠. 어,
그러셨으면 여러분들이 그러셨으면
좋겠습니다네.
>> 네.
>> 예. 어 그동안 여러분들이 올려 주신
중요한 질문들에 대해서 답을 저희가
나눠서 해 드렸고요.
>> 네.
>> 자 이번에는 또 중요한 시간입니다.
>> 어 많은 분들이 또 질문도 남겨
주시고
>> 질문이 너무 많아요.
>> 그 어 궁금해하셔서
>> 저희가 국민 성장 펀드 특집을 좀
마련해 볼까 합니다. 그래서
>> 질문에 여러분들 질문에 답하기에
앞서서 곤당커님이 일단 국민 성장
펀드가 뭔지 예. 간단하게 설명을 좀
해 주십시오.
>> 지금 간단하다고 제가 간단하게
정리한다 한다 했는데 귀여워요.
>> 일단 좀 보도록 하겠습니다. 일단
국민 성장 펀드 뭔데냐면
>> 일단 첨단 전략 사업에 장기 자금을
공급하겠다라는
정책형 투자 플랫폼이다라고 먼저
말씀을 드릴 수 있겠습니다.
>> 벌써부터 어려
>> 벌써부터 어려워. 일단 우리나라 첨단
전략 사업에 좀 장기적으로 투자를
하기 위해서 정책적으로 만들었다라고
합니다. 그래서 국민 자금은 6,억
원을 모집을 하고요. 한국
산업은행에서 1,200억 원을 출자를
하게 됩니다. 근데이 1,200억
원을 왜 출자하냐 했을 때 정부
재정이 자펀드 손실에 최대 20%를
우선 부담을 해 줍니다. 그러기
위해서 이걸 마련했다라고 보시면
되겠고요. 그래서 요렇게 두 개
합쳐서 모 펀드를 만들고 열 개의 자
펀드로 운영을 하게 된다라고 보시면
될 것 같습니다.
>> 일단 여기서 중요한게 있습니다.
뭐냐면 정부 재정으로 손실의 20%를
우산으로 배 부담해 주겠다는 건데
그건 쉽게 말해서이 펀드가 그리고
투자에서 20% 손실이 나면
>> 그거는 어 돈을 보존해 주겠다는
거지.
>> 그렇죠. 그
>> 그러니까 투자 손실이 발생했을 때
20% - 20%의 범위까지는 정부
재정이 먼저 손실을 떠안고 그 이상의
손실이 났을 때 개인에게 손실이
간다. 이렇게 간단하게
>> 예를 들면 그러면 40% 손실이 나면
>> 20%만 우리가 부담하는 거죠.
투자자들이. 그러니까 이게 단순하게만
보면이 투자는 기대값이 무조건 0보다
큰 거예요.
>> 음. 음예를 주가가 오 확률이
50%고 주가가 떨어질 확률이
50%인데 거기에 해당하는 금액이
사실은 똑같거 똑같아야 되거든요.
그러니까 이익이 났을 때 100원의
돈을 벌고 손실이 났을 때도
100원의 손실인데
>> 확률은 또 50%고 이게 사실은 주식
투자의 기대값인데 여기서 이제
100원이 손실하는 100원이
80원으로 준 거죠.
>> 그렇게 되면 기대이 투자의 기대값은
0보다 크다. 그래서 제가 볼 때이
투자는 반드시 해야 된다. 네. 그런
생각을 갖고 있습니다.
>> 그래서 국민 성장 펀드 뭐 그러면은
어디에 투자하는데 요것도 궁금해하실
거 같아요. 제가
>> 어
>> 말씀을 드리면 AI, 반도체,
2차전지, 수소, 미래차, 바이오
가치, 첨단 전략 산업 기업 관련
기업에 투자를 하게 됩니다. 그래서
조금 나눠 가지고 이제 투자를 하는데
코스피 노출도는 10% 정도 이내로
하고요. 또 신규 자금 공급 방식은
30% 이상이다라고 되어 있습니다.
비상장사에도 10% 이상 투자를 해야
되고요. 코스닥 기술 특내 상장사에도
10% 이상 투자를 해야 하는데이
코스닥 기술 특내 상장사가 정말 쉽게
말씀드리면 원래 상장을 할 때는 일정
부분 매출액과 영업 이익이 있어야
하는데 그것 없이도 어이 기술이 너무
좋다.이 기술의 가치를 보고 이제
상장한 기업들이 있습니다. 거기에다
투자를 한다라는 거고요. 어, 그
외에는 비상장자, 코스피, 코스닥,
운용사가 자유롭게 투자하는 부분이
있습니다. 그러면은 뭐 누가 살 수
있어? 누가 가입할 수 있어? 이것도
궁금해하실 것 같은데요. 일단 19세
이상 대한민국, 국민 누구나 가입이
가능합니다. 단 이제 15세에서
18세 같은 경우는 근로 소득을
증빙해야 하고요. 또 직전 3년간 한
번 이상 금융소득 종합 과세자는
전용계좌로 가입은 할 수가 없게
됩니다. 아, 그리고이 전용계좌,
일반 계좌, 납입 한도도 다른데요.
전용 계좌 같은 경우는 한 명 최대
1억 원, 연애 최대 1억 원,
5년간 총 2억 원을 납입할 수 있게
됩니다. 일반 계좌 같은 경우는 연간
3천만 원인데 세제 혜택은 없어
가지고 아마 하실 거라면 전용 계좌로
다들 많이 하시지 않을까라는 생각이
듭니다.
>> 그렇죠. 그러니까 무조건 전용 계좌로
한다로 하고 일단 네. 그다음에
국민참여형 국민 참여형 국민성장
펀드는 어떻게 가입하냐면 은행 열 곳
증권사 15곳에 가시면 되는데 일단
은행에 대부분 다입이 가능하기 때문에
여러분들이 어 편안하게 이용하시는
은행에 이제 가셔서 가입하시면
됩니다. 그리고 전용 계좌로 무조건
한다. 네.
>> 예. 그리고 가족 단위의 가입은
제한이 없고요. 그래서 부모, 뭐
성인, 자녀 각각 알아서 모두 다
가입이 가능하다라는 점 보도록
하겠습니다. 그러면은이 6,억 원을
국민들이 가입을 해야 되잖아요.
언제부터 되냐라고 하면 일단 1,
2주차 5월 22일부터 6월
4일까지는요.
서민 우선 배정이 있습니다. 조건은
근로소득 5천만 원 이하고요.
근로소득 외 종합소득은 3,800만
원 이하라는 조건이 붙습니다. 어
그래서 6,억 원의 전체 물량의
20%인 1,200억 원이요 서민
우선 배정으로 나가게 되고요. 그리고
나서 나머지 80%는 일반 소득자들이
신청을 할 수 있게 됩니다. 그래서
6월 5일부터 6월 11일까지라고
되어 있는데 아마 소신될 때까지는
판매를 계속한다라는 이야기도
있습니다. 근로소득 5천만 원
초과이신 분들은 6월 5일부터 가입이
가능하다는 거 말씀을 드릴 수
있겠습니다.
그리고 또 중요한게 세제
혜택이잖아요. 요거 중요합니다.
>> 어 그래서 세제 혜택 이것도 전용
계좌로 가입을 하셔야만 세제 혜택이
있습니다. 첫 번째 혜택은 투자금의
최대 40% 공제입니다. 연말 전정
정산에서 환급이고요. 최대 공제
금액은 1,800만 원입니다.
그리고이 40%라고 했는데 이게 투자
금액별로 구간이 달라진다라는 점
화면에서 확인해 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 두 번째 혜택으로는 배당
소득 분리과세 9%입니다. 지방세
포함면 9.9%고요. 9%고요. 일반
배당 소득세가 15%가 넘어가니까
그거랑 비교하면 6% 포인트
절감됐다라고
말씀드릴 수 있겠습니다. 말씀드린
대로 지정된 25개 판매사에서
오프라인 판매가 됩니다. 시중은행
10개, 증권사 15개. 말씀드린
대로 국민 성장 펀드 전용 계좌로
가입을 하시면 좋을 것 같고요.
그래서 가입할 때 뭐 필요한게 여러
가지 여러 가지 있을 텐데 무엇보다도
소득 확인 증명서가 필요해하다라는 점
말씀을 드릴 수 있겠습니다. 근데
우리가 막 만약 이거 최고예요,
좋아요만 말씀을 드릴 건 아니고
명심해야 될 것, 확인해야 될 것도
있잖아요. 네.
>> 원칙 5년간 중도 해지 불가입니다.
>> 아, 요게 중요하죠. 요거
중요합니다. 그래서 가입후 3년 이내
매도하면 우리가 앞에 설명을 드렸던
세제 혜택 전액 반환해야 한다네
>> 어 나 3년 안에 5년 안에 빼야
돼. 이런 자금으로 투자하시면 사실
예. 그래서 혜택을 누릴 수 없다라는
거 보시면 좋을 거 같고요.
마지막으로는 주식 시장에 어떤 영향
미칠까 요것도 궁금해하실 거 같아요.
근데 정책 테마가 만들어질 수
있겠죠.어요 그죠? 어, 요펀드가
산다. 요펀드가 투자한다라고 하면
>> 특히나 비상장이나
성장기업들, 성장주들은
>> 어, 자금 조달 효과를 얻을 수
있다라고 하고요. 코스닥, 중소형,
성장주 심리 개선도 될 것 같다라는
전망들 있습니다.
>> 네. 야, 참 간단하게 했는데도
내용이 이렇게 많을만큼 조금
복잡해요.
>> 근데 이제 짧게 그냥 어떤 머릿속에
탁 넣어 드리려면 이런 거예요. 왜
이런 일이 나왔냐면
>> 그동안 이제 우리나라 지난 한 3년간
보면 우리나라가 우리나라 산업을
위해서 투자한게 없는 거예요.
>> 그니까 기업들이
>> 성장을 못 해. 그러니까 안 되겠다.
정부가
>> 돈을 마련할게. 그래 가지고 한
30조 마련하기로 했어요. 정.
그래서이 30조를 들고
>> 우리가 기업에게 지원할게. 너
바이오야? 너 신기술 있어? 오케이.
갖다 써. 성장해.
>> 요게 이제 정책이 원래 지향하는
목표예요.
>> 요게 끝이에요. 근데 이제 그 30조
중에 20조는 사실상 꽂주는 거예요.
돈 필요하지. 이거 갖고 개발해.
이거 갖고 설비해. 그럼 나중에
갚아. 이자로 갚아.요 정도예요.
근데 그 나머지 분야는
>> 이거는 꺼 주는게 아니라 투자한
거예요. 정부가. 그래. 어떤 거는
정부가 야, 이건 내가 너한테 지분
투자한다.이 돈을 넣고 나 집 줘.
>> 음. 이렇게 하는게 이제 정부의 직접
투자가 또 한 몇 조가 있어요? 3,
4조가 있고요. 3조 정도가 있고.
그럼 그 나머지는 정부가 원래는 내가
직접 지분 투자해도 되는데 A테크 뭐
B이오 여기다 직접 투자해도 되는데이
>> 투자가 만약에 성공을 해. 그래갖고
정부가 돈을 넣어서이 기업을 살렸는데
이게 막 상장이 되고 막 날아가
>> 대박이 터졌어.
>> 대박이 나는 거지.
그 기회가 있잖아 정진기술이 있는 정
다 잘 수 있으니까
>> 대박이 날 것 같거든요. 그러니까
이재명 대통령이 생각한 거지. 이거는
왜 과실을 정부가 먹냐?
>> 음.
>> 국민과 나누자. 이렇게 되는 거야.
그래서 정부가 직접 투자하는 것도
있지만
>> 한 6조 정도는 따로 빼는 거예요.
아니, 6조가 아니고 6,억 정도는
따로 빼는 거예요. 그래서 요거는
국민 여러분도 여기다 투자를
하십시오. 그럼요 투자금을 갖고 좋은
기업들에 미리미리 투자를 해서 상장도
되고 뭐 기업이 커지면
>> 그렇게 해서 얻어진 성과를요 펀드에
투자하신 국민 여러분께 나눠
>> 드립니다.
>> 이렇게 해서 한 트랙을 열었다 이게
보시면 되는 거예요.
>> 음.
그래서 어
정부가 요런 걸 만들었다라는 거
보시면 되는 거고 그러니까 어 그래
그러면 나 대신 어 정부가 신기술 또
좋은 회사들 다 이렇게 금융 회사들이
함께 해서 곤란했으니까 나는 여기
믿고 투자하면 그래도 어 내가 혼자
하는 거보다 좋은 기업들 곤란했으니까
나중에 성과가 날 거야 이렇게
생각하시면 된다는 거예요.
>> 그러면 그런데 뭐 이렇게 복잡해라고
하는데 복잡하실 건 하나도 없어요.
어느 은행을 가든 어느 증권사를 가든
사실은 국민 여러분이 가입하시는
펀드는 그냥 똑같다라고 보시면 돼.
야, 나 삼성증권 가서 가입했는데 내
친구는 국민에서 가했대. 성과가 다른
거 아니야?
>> 아니에요. 똑같아요. 국민 여러분은
어디 가서 가입하시나? 성과가
똑같습니다. 단,
>> 여러분은 똑같지만 여러분에겐 똑같은
성과를 돌려 드리지만 이제
내부적으로는
>> 어느
돈이 들어왔는데 사실은 그 돈을 이제
한 열 개 정도 되는 자산 운용사가
나눠서
>> 네.
>> 투자하거든요. A 회사는 나는
바이오에 집중 투자하겠습니다. 나는
로보트 회사에 투자하겠습니다. 이렇게
해서 내부적으로는 성과가 좀 달라질
수 있어요.
>> 근데 그렇다 하더라도 그걸 한꺼번에
모아서 국민 여러분께 돌려 주니까
예. 어디 가서나 똑같다. 그러니까
>> 펀드 이거 들어요. 저거 들어요.
고민하실 필요는 없다. 그냥 가까운
은행이나 증권사 가서 하시면 된다.
네.
>> 그리고 온라인 판매도 한다고 합니다.
그래서 전체 물량의 한 50%
수준으로 온라인 판매도 가능하니까
여러분들이 이용하시는 은행에
온라인으로 가입하시면 될 거 같고요.
>> 어, 근데이 국민 성장 펀드에
관련돼서 또 질문하고 어, 질문이 좀
많았어요.
>> 구체적인 질문들을 저희가 한번 예시를
답변을 드려 볼게요. 한번 볼까요?
첫째 질문 보도록 하겠습니다.
반도체와 지수 위주로 직접 투자하면서
높은 수익률을 보고 있는데요. 펀드
수익률이 현재 상승장의 수익률만큼은
될까요? 반도체 수익성이 좋은
시기인만큼 고민이 됩니다라고 질문
남겨 주셨습니다.
>> 음. 그러니까 수익률을 예측하기는 좀
힘든데 예. 저희가이 투자의 핵심은
뭐냐면 일단 아까도 말씀드린 것처럼
20% 손실을 방어한다. 이런 투자가
흔치 않다라는 거죠. 두 번째는
뭐냐면 세제 혜택이 있어요. 어
그래서 소득 공제 혜택이 있기 때문에
근로소득자인
같은 경우에는 일정 부분 가입하는게
전 맞다라고 보고 있고 대신 아까
말씀드린 것처럼
>> 어 5년 동안 환매가 금지돼 있기
때문에 너무 많은 자금으로을
투자해 놓으면 사실은 어 투자 직접
투자하는데 조금 뭐 제약도 있고 어
다른 금액이 줄 수 있잖아요. 그래서
좀 장기적인 차원에서 내가 투자이이
정도 금액은 투자할 수 있어. 세제
혜택 봐야지. 그 정도의 금액으로
하셨으면 좋겠다는 말씀을
>> 드립니다네.
>> 이게 아주 기초인데요. 돈을 꺼 주고
>> 받는 돈은 이자예요.
>> 근데 이거는 명확하게
>> 예. 투자 펀드입니다. 그러니까 원금
보장이 안 되는 거예요. 원래는.
그래서 전액 손실도 가능한데 이거는
펀드인데도 불구하고 20%까지는 손실
나는 걸 보전해 준다니까 없는
상품이거든요. 시장에 요게
매력이에요. 그러니까 아 -2까지는
절대 손해를 안 보는구나. 이게
매력이지.
>> 지금 내가 투자하고 있는 반도체보다
수익이 높을까요?이 상방을 보는게
포커스는 아니라는 점. 네. 맞아요.
>> 하방을 막아준다. 이게 매력이다.
>> 네. 두 번째 질문 가보도록
하겠습니다. 어 펀드가 코스닥과
비상장사에도 많이 투자한다고 들었는데
조금 불안하기도 합니다. 정기 예금을
고집하는 70대 부모님께 ETF
가입과 국민 성장 펀드 중에 어떤
것을 추천하는게 좋을까요라는 질문을
주셨습니다.
>> 근데이 펀드의 핵심은 저거든요.
그러니까 코스닥의 성장성이 높은
회사에 투자하고 또 비장성사에
투자해서 자금 조달을 원활하게 해서
성장시키겠다 이거기 때문에 거기에
대해서 오히려 어 불안보다도 매력을
느끼실 필요가 있어요. 그런데
전문가들이 이제 분석하고
>> 또 하나 흥미로운 지점은 좋은 회사가
이렇게 있지만
자금이 들어가면요 좋게도 돼 돼요.
일종의 선수는 아니죠. 네. 어,
그렇기 때문에 저는이 국민성장 펀드와
함께 어, 이런 펀드가 대한민국의
산업생택의 미친형에 클 것으로 보고
있고 그런 가능성을 한번 저희가 보는
것도 좋겠다라는 말씀을 드립니다.
그래서 70대 부모님이 이제 안정적
투자를 원하시고 뭐 그러실 텐데 아,
저는 가입한다. 예. 국민장펀드에
가입한다 추천드리는데 너무 큰 자금은
하지 마시고 어 예를 들어서 뭐 그
일정 부분에만 투자하시면서 그런
혜택을 누르시는게 좋지 않을까 저는
생각합니다.
>> 네. 사실 이제 대부분의 자금이
코스닥이랑 비상장 기술이 좋은 회사들
좀 필요한 회사들에게 가잖아요. 근데
이제 코스닥도 사실은 좋은 회사가
많은데 우리가 늘 아 어떤 회사가
진짜 기술이 있는지 모르겠어라고
하는데 이걸 정부가 대신 골라 주니까
너무 좋고요.
>> 그다음에 이제 사실 대박은 비상장일
때 미리 지분을 갖고 있다가 나중에이
상장이 되면 이게 대박이 나거든요.
근데 누구나도 다 알지만 좋은 비상장
회사에 지분을 가질 기회가 없어요.
>> 맞아요.
>> 우리는 없어.
>> 네. 우리 개인 투자자들은 없고.
예. 그런데 여러분이 여기
투자하시면이 펀드가 비상장에 투자하기
때문에 사실상 내가 평소에는 잡아보지
못하는 초기 이니셔티브를 잡을 수
있다. 요게 이제 대박의 포인트가
된다라는 건데 다만이 질문하신 분한테
제가 조금 걸리는 거는 70대
부모님이거든요.
>> 네. 그러니까 이제 5년간 돈을
사실상 이제 묶긴다라고 보는데 너무
고령이시면 아유 나 1, 2년 있다가
애들한테 뭐 상속도 해야 되고 돈
필요한데 이러신 분들한테는 조금
장기일 수도 있어요. 고령자분들께는.
그 부분만 조금 한번 가족회를 해
보시죠. 근데 요즘도 돼요. 70대
너무 젊으셔서 네. 전혀 걱정 안
하셔도 됩니다.
>> 네. 그래서 다음으로 온 질문은요.
어, 전체 자산 중에 몇 퍼센트
정도를이 펀드에 넣는게 좋을까요라고
말씀하십니다. 계속해서 저희가
말씀드리죠. 5년 동안 헌매가 안
되다 보니까
>> 이게 뭐 개인마다 다르실 것 같기는
한데
>> 그래도 뭐 또 우리 투자자 여러분들은
해답을 원하시니까
>> 그니까 정확하게 말씀드리기 좀
힘들어요. 그러니까 자산배는
개개인갱별로 다르기 때문에 저희가 뭐
1천만 원 하세요. 2천만 원
하세요. 그럼 속 시원하지만 그렇게
말씀드리기 힘들다. 대신 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 세 가지 정도 고려를
하시라. 첫 번째는 5년 동안 묶여야
된다. 두 번째는 뭐냐면 가입 한도가
있으니까 세제택을 일단 고려해서
>> 네.
>> 그걸 최대 한도로 했으면 좋겠다.
>> 예를 들어서 1800만 원에 소득
공제가 되잖아요. 그러면 1800만
원 이상은 투자하는 거죠. 어 그런
식으로 이제 생각해 보면 좋을 거
같고
>> 세 번째는
>> 어 그니까 너무 많은 또 자금을 하면
이제 기회 비용이 크지 않습니까?
그죠? 그러니까 지금 막 반호체도
투자해야 되고 지수 ETF도 해야
되고 이런 상황 속에서 너무 많은
그니까 최근에 또 많이 하는 질문이
관련해서 저 반도체로 수익 많이
났는데 다 팔아서 여기 몰빵 한번
할게요.
>> 그건 아니다. 그건 아니다. 기회
비용이 클 수 있다. 그런 말씀을
드립니다.
>> 그네. 네. 네. 다음 질문으로
가보도록 하겠습니다. 아, 이재명
대통령을 믿고 가입하려고 했는데 가입
기간이 5년이라서요.
향후에 정권이 바뀌더라도 현재의
조건과 혜택 그대로 유지될까요라고
질문 주셨습니다.
>> 음.이 이 여러분이 세금과 관련해서는
헌법에 써 있어요. 그리고 어느 나라
다 마찬가지입니다. 조세
법률주의예요. 그러니까 사실상
법이라고 보시면 돼요. 여기 이제
아까 이광수 대표님 말씀해준 것처럼
세제 혜택도 있고 뭐 소득 공제
혜택도 있고 하잖아요. 이게 지금
조재 특례 제한법의 관련 근거를 다
마련하고 하는 지금 상황이거든요.
그러니까 이거는 정권이 아무리
바뀌더라도 예, 지금 가입한이 시점에
적용되는 법률이 그대로 적용되니까
이런 부분은 걱정하지 마시고 예,
판단하셔도 좋겠습니다.
>> 음. 네.
어, 뭐 걱정 안 하셔도 된다라는
말씀 함께 들어봤습니다. 다음 질문
빠르게가 볼게요. 펀드 수익률을
떠나서 소득 공제 혜택이 크다고
들었는데 종합소득세를 환급받는
프리랜서나 소득이 없는 무직자와 어,
정년 퇴직자는 메리트가 없을까요라고
질문 주셨습니다.
어, 소득 공제 같은 경우에는 실제로
근로 소득이 받으시는 분들이 혜택이
더 크니까 일종에 장점이 큰데
상대적으로 무직 무직이거나 아니면
퇴직자분들은 크게 메리트가 없을 순
있죠.
>> 대신이 펀드는 배당 소득에 대해서
분리세가 들어가거든요.
>> 그래서 관련해서는 충분히 어 혜택이
일부 있을 수 있다. 그래서 잘
고려하셔서 어 판단하시면 좋으실 것
같습니다.
>> 네. 그러니까 음
>> 다시 한번 말씀드리만 하방을 정부가
마이너스 20까지는 막아 준다. 아유
그럼 20까지는 손실이 나도 끄덕
없네. 이것도 좋고요. 이득이 많이
났어.
>> 그래서 배당이 와.
>> 그래도 예 9.9% 분리 과세를
하니까 다른 펀드나 이쪽에서 받는
배당보다 예 거의 절반 정도가 되니까
이익이 나도 사실상 예 추가로 돈을
더 많이 갈 수 있는 좋은 구조다.
일단 이렇게 말씀드립니다.
>> 네. Q&A 이렇게 좀 전반적으로
마무리를 해. 말씀하신 것 중에 이제
박정 대표님이 인상적인 말씀을
하셨어요. 뭐냐면 일반적으로 비상장
회사에 투자하는 기회가 없죠. 어
펀드에 가입하거나 이러지 않으면
>> 그런데 이번 기회를 통해서 여러분들이
성장이 유망한 그런 한국의 기업들에
투자할 수 대신 투자하실 수 있다라는
그 기회가 될 수 있다고 보고 있고
그리고 저희가 이게 자산 운용사들이
있지 않습니까? 그러면 자산
운영사들이이 자산을 운용할 거
아니에요.
>> 그러면 엄한 주식을 안 사지 않는다는
얘기죠. 그러니까 이미 뭐 평가도
하고 이미 투자한 회사들
>> 그리고 충분히 검토한 회사들을 하기
때문에 전문가들을 믿으시고 어 한번
어 투자를 해 보시는 것도 저는
좋다는 생각입니다.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 음
>> 어 우리 증시 관련해서 늘 불안해
아우 손해 보면 어떻해 이게 사실은
예전부터 갖고 있던 불안감인데요.
그런 불안감 없이 정부 정책에 맞춰서
예 원금도 보 거의 거의 보장되고 어
좋은 기회가 되니까 적극적으로 하실
수 있는 한도만큼은 예 적극적으로
검토해 보셔도 좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 그렇죠. 세제탁 한도 채우시고
그다음에 참여한 무조건 한다. 이런
계획 가지시고 대신 5년 동안 안
되니까 강조하지만 어 여유 작업으로
하시고 어 급한 돈으로 하거나 뭐
빚을 내서 하거나 이러면 안 된다는
말씀을 드립니다. 네. 음,
>> 일단 이렇게 저희가 오늘 어,
오랜만에 돌아온 Q&A 해 봤고 예,
우리 독자님들 제일 많이 질문 주셨던
국민 성장 펀대에 관해서도 궁금증을
확 풀어봤는데요. 역시 우리는 소통의
왕들이에요.
>> 저희
>> 이렇게 친절할 수가 없습니다. 우리가
>> 잘한 거죠. 네. 그죠. 그죠.
>> 이렇게 친절한 저희가 또 여러분께
잠깐 또 공지상을 하나 알려 드려야
되겠네요. 저희가 5월 30일
또 주식 아가방 강연이 있습니다.
>> 주식 아가방 예. 네이버에서
검색하시고 신청하셔도 되고요. 저기
주아가.co.kr로 c.kr로
신청하셔도 되고 이번에는 저희가
수도권 한 번은 저 위쪽 1파주로
가고요. 한은 밑에 쪽 위래 송파
요렇게 북과 나무로다가 한번가
봅니다.
>> 근처에 계시는 분들은 신청해 주시기
바랍니다. 그니까 저희가이 오프라인
오프라인 강연인데 이제 무료 강연이고
이제 저희가 강연을 하는데
>> 사실 제 계획은 신청자가 줄어들면
이제 좀 안 하고 싶거든요.
>> 근데 더 많아 줘요. 도말아 줘요.
그래서 아 멈추지 못하고 있습니다.
>> 아니 안 그래도 얼마 전에도 아
쉬어야겠어. 강연 더 이상 못 하겠어
하신 거 같은데
>> 와요근데 근데 여러분들 그 아침에
일찍 오시고 그리고 한 자리에서 거의
네다섯 시간을 앉아 계시거든요.
>> 근데 그 눈빛을 볼 때마다 또 기운을
받습니다. 그래서 여러분들 뵐 때마다
너무 좋고 많이들 오셔서
>> 저희가 같이 얘기도 하고 소통도
하시고 대신 어
>> 처음 오시는 분들이 오시는 거예요.
한번 들으신 분들이 또 오실 필요는
없어요. 내용이 똑같고 똑같이 혼나는
겁니다. 정신교육.
>> 정신교육. 예. 그렇기 때문에
여러분들 특히 처음 주식 투자하시고
그리고 이런 강연을 들어본 적이
없다. 주식 관련대 그런 분들이
많이들 오셔서
>> 어 기본에 대해서 저희가 생각해 보고
어 같이 고민해 보는 시간을 또
갖도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네.
>> 예. 저희 오늘 또 AS 센터를
통해서 여러분들의 질문에 대한 답을
드렸고요. 저희한테 많이 질문
주세요. 어, 좋은 질문을 드 주시면
저희가 그만큼 더 발전할 수도 있고
여러분들한테 더 크게 도움이 될 수
있을 것으로 생각합니다. 12시에
만나요는 항상 여러분하고 같이 옆에서
어, 꿋꿋하게 손잡고가 보도록
하겠습니다. 오늘도 여러분 함께
해주셔서 감사하고요.
>> 감사하고요. 한 말씀만 더 할게요.
제일은 저희가 정말로 아껴두었던
>> 초특급 슈퍼 울트라 메가톤급 VVIP
슈퍼스타가 옵니다.
>> 저희까지 예. 거기까지만
말씀드립니다. 네. 네.
거기까지입니다.
>> 오늘도 좋았지만 내일 더 좋을
겁니다.
>> 기대해 주시.
>> 아 알겠습니다. 여러분 저희가 계속
너네 왜 이렇게 더 좋아지냐?
>> 어디까지 좋아질 거니? 네.
>> 일단 10만까지 가보겠습니다. 동접자
10만. 여러분 많이 도아
여러분 잠깐만. 아니, 여러분, 왜
스마트폰으로만 보시는 거예요? PC로
같이 켜 놓으면 되잖아.
>> 그렇지. 다단계 영업해 주셔야죠.
어,
>> 피라미드로 갑니다, 우리는.
>> PC 켜 놓고 스마트폰 같이 보고
이러는 거 아닙니까?
>> 아, 그럼요. 그
>> 그래야만 되지. 언제 돼요?
>> 예, 여러분, 오늘도 함께 해 주셔서
너무 감사드리고요. 저희 또 내일
뵙도록 하겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 안녕.
เฮ